ition we we sparked one up on New Year's
Eve we put filled up that hole oh the
actual oh my god rolling paper that came
with big bamboo that was the first time
I really went out where we're live right
now so just let everybody know we're
talking about Cheech and Chong yeah huge
just across the I think was across the
double the the double album dude you
have a flip phone as you act I do I do I
snapped out Oh T G brought that you
figured out create less data yeah that's
that's my mom's out what it is
yeah well two things one your phone is
always [ __ ] with you it's yeah it's
notifying and you know it yeah and I
just didn't want to be a part of that
anymore I wanted to you know be a little
more connected to life outside you'd
still call people well this is so this
is actually a new flip phone from
t-mobile
Alcatel and it has kos which is so it's
not really a trackable OS although
Google put are serious about this well
I'm very serious about yeah oh yeah and
you know all the apps are all they're
all tracking you they're all doing all
kinds of [ __ ] but initially really just
to not be you know a slave to this thing
yeah and the further I got into it the
more I liked it and you don't really
need it now I have a device with me
that's off this works as a hotspot so I
can turn into a hotspot if I really
really really needed to do something but
what do you need right text phone call
right and if there's something that I
really need to look up you just turn
around and say hey can someone Google
this for me they do it there's always
someone around are you texting on that
thing yeah yeah do t9 they have a it's
like a t9 it's a little bit better it's
their version of predictive texting yeah
I really am serious about it well you
should be yeah and everyone should yeah
the problem we have all this cool [ __ ]
all this great technology but the
business model [ __ ] us all I mean six
years ago I had the first Amazon echo
I'm like this is groundbreaking
Dvorak Mike my co-host he was laughing
at me he's like why would you bring a
spy device into your house it look I'm
just testing this out if at an Apple
logo on it everyone would be losing
their [ __ ] right now but it didn't and I
loved it hooked it up to the light and
all that stuff going and
as I started to understand what it was
really doing and what is really
communicating all these things right
down to like your Roku remote you picked
that up it's communicating with home
base mm-hmm so all the stuffs I got rid
of all of it what's got rid of it um you
know I was listening to one of Sam
Harris's podcast and he was talking when
someone that said and they had a really
good great quote that we didn't realize
that our data was something valuable the
right we didn't realize it was a
commodity and it's being sold not just a
commodity that's kind of value but
insanely fast dreamless yeah but that's
where Facebook makes all their money
that's where Google makes all their
money everybody yeah every make it from
your data and you never really
understood what you were doing when you
signed off to give that data away when
you signed the terms of agreements and
you're like yeah yeah yeah whatever
and nobody reads through that [ __ ] you
know what's even more egregious is
there's a company called plaid PLA ID
just sold the visa for I think four or
five billion dollars and it's the the
financial back-end we're kind of like a
bridge between all these apps that can
do stuff with your bank account and your
bank account so instead of so if you
have an app like venmo or [ __ ] you know
name any payment hash app I didn't want
to disparage anyone who might be
advertised cash at PayPal well PayPal do
it
PayPal has their own system but what you
do is you sign up and you literally give
this app your username and login to your
bank account instead of an API or some
kind of programming interface just lets
the app talk to your bank account and
put money in take it out he can do
anything
it's in fact it is just like screams
screen scraping it's going you can go
through anything that's connected to
your bank account it can look at and
they do and at Credit Karma another
great a great example of it and they are
just sucking out all of your information
when you pay your bills who you pay
first why you know if you have you know
what your pattern is of credit card
payment moving stuff around so you think
you're just using it as a as a utility
but they're tracking your [ __ ] life
dude you're really concerned about this
everybody will get the world they
deserve you know so I'm trying to
protect myself and people I love also
you know the drone can't target me that
easily with this protecting you Joe
thank you it seems somewhat inevitable
right that this connection that we have
to technology gets deeper and deeper
into our lives but that what what
disturbs me is that there's these giant
corporations that are not just profiting
off of our connection but then they're
using that money and that influence to
affect a lot of things in our culture
well they're enslaving you yeah so
Credit Karma is a great example which
also just sold for seven billion dollars
it was literally changing your behavior
to get a higher credit score and this
credit score isn't really even an
official credit score it's the one that
they kind of made up so they'll say pay
your utilities on time then we'll raise
your credit score your credit score is
higher now we can lend you this money
you see so they're training people to do
certain things like the progressive app
for insurance it's training you to drive
in a quote unquote responsible manner
because you get discounts if you you
know don't brake too hard if you're not
accelerating if you're not breaking
speed limits etc is it hooked up to the
GPS oh yeah so it knows your speeds and
everything is monitoring everything if
your braking velocity all of that [ __ ]
oh yeah so they take that into
consideration every month well that's
the whole point the point is to train
the user to be a good fiscally good
person whatever dad's just because you
want to save some money
well of course everyone does that you're
gonna be you're gonna be forced into it
like I just got health insurance new
health insurance and they're oh we
download the app and if you download the
app we'll give you a break why because
they're going to tell me to do things
this app to saying you know now it's
small things but it'll start telling you
stand up you know move around and if you
follow it if you follow it then you'll
get a discount so we're really really
becoming enslaved that way that's what
that is definitely a way to look at it
yeah that's the business model yeah and
it gets more and more immersive yeah
yeah oh yeah I did I didn't know the
progressives
does that that's all of them do you have
all of them the insurance company yes
that makes sense I mean that's that
would be the best way to figure out if
you're actually a good driver of you're
just some [ __ ] who gets lucky well
yeah I mean that's kind of the the
marketing is like you know if you're a
good guy don't worry about it but they
keep pushing they keep pushing you know
they'll just keep telling you and you
don't have to have the app active for
that to be tracked or monitored that was
one of the grossest arguments I heard
after the whole Snowden thing like what
do you care if you're not breaking the
law that's changing a little bit I have
a 29 year old daughter and she
definitely had that that mindset and her
friends did it's changing you know now
it's like okay we totally get it
they're tracking all of our [ __ ] so
we're gonna might not use this and we'll
leave the phone at home there's a little
bit of that creeping in but in general
it's like crack you know how can you do
with it's not easy it's I mean this this
phone it's sometimes like ah I could but
no it's like and I just have to stand
back and go do I really need to have
this information right at this very
moment do I really need to do this no
typically no yeah when I feel any sort
of anxiety or boredom I just grab the
phone
it's just instantly my little my little
soothing blanket or my little teething
thing absolutely pinky and I play a game
with myself you know I'll get myself
points as I'm driving around like person
walking on the street holding the phone
in the hand one point you don't need to
actually hold the phone in your hand and
women holy crap they got two phones
sometimes with a little you know a
little button plug so it doesn't fall
off they got their bag maybe they got
that kid or a stroller and it's a pop-up
bomb they're doing all and just they're
all over the place all the time so it's
one point for just holding it to if
you're walking and doing something I see
a lot of that how many points if you
have a kid and you're walking and
looking at your phone that seems like
that be it's the bit if you're in the
car ten points if you're walking with
your kid on the phone it's five points
and you can hit a hundred with in five
minutes it's it's crazy it's zombies
yeah when you start to really pay
attention to it when you're above people
have a truck and I want to look down
on my truck you can see people texting
and it's stunning
how many people are on the highway
texting at the same time think I
rear-ended with my truck say maybe two
months ago in Austin you know right
after stoplight and I was in the
left-hand Lane it's gonna turn left
BAM full speed it was maybe 30 35 miles
an hour
you know the girls airbags deployed
she's like I'm like ho and if I was in
the in the truck I'm like yeah okay I
get out and the whole front end is
destroyed she's dazed and like so I'm
trying to pry the door open and yeah
there I see the phone on the floor still
open and then her excuse was well my
brake didn't work okay I got my break
didn't work does that ever happened my
brakes did my rear end to the same thing
there was a slowdown on the right lane
and some some guy plowed right into me
and I asked the cop said oh this is five
times five times a day yeah I'm sure
it's crazy yeah it's it's weird that
that sort of snuck up on us that there's
this thing that's incredibly incredibly
addictive I was with my family this past
weekend in Dallas and we're at this
event as we're walking through this
crowd I'm like look how many people are
on their phones this is crazy like
everyone it's it was just you're going
through the crowd of this store and
everyone is just looking at their phone
just yeah it's like a zombie movie they
don't know they're zombies truly is a
zombie apocalypse yeah truly yeah and
the weirdest why I mean it gives you a
little bit of reward every now and then
someone has a funny meme like but that's
that's what Silicon Valley figured out
is that the pie vlog in response and the
you know all the all the brain impulses
you get from a like or a you know a
retweet or whatever it is or even just
something bleep oh yeah oh and we have
different sounds bling blong all this
before we go any further we should give
you credit you're the reason why all
this started you are the original pod
father the legitimate one like if
there's a lot of people claiming that
yeah you're the guy who made the very
first podcast you even came up with the
name of it right no I didn't come up
with the name of the name
well let me go back to to the beginning
because actually the technology of
podcasting was invented in 2000 so
before anyone was podcasting before
there was
an iPod interestingly I was living in
Amsterdam at the time and I was working
with Dave Winer who had really invented
blogging and he had created this RSS
syndication format and he had software
you could blog and then an aggregator
kind of like you know Google Reader at
the time and you couldn't you know read
blogs it was kind of like a two-way
communication thing was interesting and
a lot of people are starting to use it
and in Amsterdam they had cable modems
rolled out everywhere and cable modems
were sold at the time as always
on Internet it wasn't fast it was just
[ __ ] on you didn't have to dial in
which was oh my god this is great you
know this was a huge improvement didn't
have to kick someone off the phone line
all that so the the the the experience
of multimedia was [ __ ] like you wanted
to hear a song or play a video it was
like click wait wait wait download wait
you know it would probably download and
then open up some kind of player and
then it was not an experience there was
nothing nothing there that made sense so
and I always wanted to broadcast on the
unit that's always been my thing from
the moment I saw it so I came up with
this concept of the last yard I said
what if you had a little thing running
on your computer in the background that
would know if there's something you
wanted let's just forget that how it
knows part it would download it and it
would tell you that there was something
new when it already had it on its local
hard drive so you remove the whole wait
experience because you don't know you
don't know that this computer has been
downloading something you've wanted it
just tells you oh it's here which is you
know it's not abnormal in media you're
the 6 o'clock news most of its produced
before the actual broadcast so I took
this idea to Dave and I said we need to
come up with something that can download
a media file that I program somehow like
this is going to show up and then it
downloads it and only tells me when it's
there and I can click on it it plays
immediately and it it took some
convincing he didn't exactly understand
what I was saying he probably thought I
have [ __ ] MTV God in fact that's
exactly what he thought
and and then I actually demonstrated to
him what I wanted to do in his own
software and he said okay I'm gonna do
this but only on the condition you never
ever ever [ __ ] use my software again
because that was horrible what you just
did and so we created the enclosure
element in RSS and so for two years we
were doing back and forth you know like
movie files and stuff and I'll click and
would open up and the experience was
good until I saw my first iPod friend of
mine said look at this I'm like oh this
is the white one with the big deal on it
that was a good one right they got high
after a while like hard drive and I
looked at and went this is not a digital
Walkman this is a [ __ ] radio receiver
because I had one I had a Sony AM radio
trend receiver which is a little
solid-state thing like this is a radio
this can receive radio programming and
so I said about again with my fantastic
programming sales skills to make a
little application and you're the iPod
at the time you still had to sync it to
iTunes is how you got music onto it back
in the day and so you could put a mp3
file into a blog post basically but it
was a special attachment really and so
this program would just be looking all
the time is there something new is there
something new oh there's something new
download it then click trip it so that
it's synchronized to the iPod and it
works now not being a programmer that's
actually Kevin marks a guy was working
at Apple sent me a version of the script
that actually worked that was helpful
and I said about creating a radio show
which we didn't have the name podcast
yet and I wanted to be able to talk to
developers software developers who could
create receivers so we had iPod or iPod
or X iPod or lemon all the all these
different applications which kind of did
the same thing and because I was talking
to developers I called it the daily
source code so I did every day and
source code is kind of what the
developers work in and I was really
talking to them like okay well the guys
over in New Zealand they you know
they've created this version of
and it's really working well and we
discovered all kinds of crazy [ __ ] like
you subscribe to a feed because we know
one to thought it through we would try
and download you know everything you had
in that feed all at once so trying to
download 50 episodes and we still had
kind of always on internet so everything
would crunch and die and this just kept
building and building and other people
started doing these and we called them
soliloquies and little bundles of joy
and all kinds of really dumb names and
the danny Gregoire guy who was just
listening he said oh that's this is a
podcast and the name stuck now Ben
Hammersley from The Guardian years
earlier had actually used the term
podcast somewhere in an article which
there was no podcasting at the time but
he envisioned that and and called the
podcast so he's the guy named it he used
the term but I would say Danny Gregoire
really named what we were doing at the
time so so and that's when I didn't name
myself the pod father but people started
calling me that
and it just grew from there and that
went really fast before I knew what the
BBC was calling and interviews here and
there I'm like holy [ __ ] something
blowing up here yeah and it wasn't until
the big moment was I got a call from
Steve Jobs and he says he actually was
Eddy Cue you know who's big man on
campus there now he says that can you
meet with Steve I'm like check the
calendar yeah so it was in where's the
d3 conference like San Diego I think
went there and I met with him for an
hour and it was an O and I had I've met
a lot of interesting people my my best
meeting to date had been Quincy Jones
where I got drunk with him for an hour
on a live radio show oh yeah that was
fantastic
and so here's Steve Jobs in the flesh
and the first thing I noticed is he's
got a weird list but I'd not really
heard before really yeah it's like well
okay so he hides it when he does those
maybe doing what he's projecting is but
he was much more personable and it's
just the two of us but first he's he's
he's [ __ ] pissed off and he's yelling
about they [ __ ] up Wi-Fi and I learned
later that his his plan always for the
iPhone was to not be a cellphone but to
use Wi-Fi networks around the world and
oh yeah and because you know Cisco ever
had changed the the way Wi-Fi works and
the way the authentication works that it
really wouldn't be that seamless but
that was his his vision and you know so
actually I thought to myself you should
probably calm down make you say and then
he was talking about oh no Eddy Cue says
yeah you know the Raa called and they
got a problem with the with how we're
able to you know record sounds on the
Mac you know breaking any kind of
encryption and I said I it's actually
kind of important because in order to
record stuff we're using like audio
hijack Pro and all these all these
different kinds of tools and I said mom
I hope hope they don't do that because
it's kind of important for production
and Steve went [ __ ] it
tell them to [ __ ] themselves this is
tools our guys need and then he said
Adam I'd like to put podcasting in
iTunes are you okay with that I like are
you kidding me
yes I'll give you my director got built
a directory of podcast art it off
absolutely and then it was kind of funny
so then maybe what year is this 2004
something like that I think yeah 2004
2005 timeframe and then Jamie may you
can find it if you want it's a pretty
funny video so he announces this on
stage playing my my podcast where I just
rail on the Mac it's you take a look at
it's pretty funny it's like it's the one
video that they're really legitimizes me
in the world of podcasting thank you
Steve I really appreciate it oh yeah you
got you gotta check this out this is
hilarious is so great it's free and I
think what we're gonna see is an
advertising supported model emerge just
like free radio here's another Adam
Curry is one of the guys that invented
podcasting and he has a podcast called
the daily source let me go ahead and
subscribe to that and we can go listen
to his latest one you know just click on
your daily
show number ones live in Eden something
remarkable is happening here radio is
springing free of the regulated
gatekeepers who've managed what you've
been here since Radio is invented it's
jumping into the hands of anyone at all
with something or nothing to say that's
right it's show number 180 and it's
Friday everybody thank God
I've actually had to restart the show
three times my Mac has been acting up
like a [ __ ]
it's something to do with
the file system he knew exactly what he
was doing bro I'm telling you he didn't
know I love Kara Swisher her mouth feels
like it was happening larious and then
he he sent me an email later and he said
I'm gonna introduce you to some people
in venture capital kleiner perkins
Sequoia Capital which I kind of took is
to thank you and I went on to raise a
lot of money from those companies to
build my podcast network what what was
the first like what year was your first
podcast the first one you released well
so that was 2003 I guess 2003 Wow so you
did what was going on before you was
there anything was there any other well
people have been putting well we had
real video and real audio if you
remember the low low grade streaming
stuff and but this really made it did
two things I mean it solved the
bandwidth problem for downloading that
was the first and now that's no longer
an issue of course but it put the
subscription model into place and
because neither I or Dave why nor have
ever patented any of this it's
completely free and open so no one owns
it and that was that was the mission I'm
very proud of that that's beautiful
because you know otherwise if someone
they're like Spotify is now trying to
buy podcasting by buying up all these
networks and they'll make it exclusive
and granted they're trying to switch
from a music company to an audio company
but ultimately look at all the
applications that are out there that are
really good people love them you know
the Apple podcasts app I use overcast I
like that a lot there's tons of
different ones and it's all because
there's an open standard that no one can
control and Silicon Valley loves
controlling [ __ ] in fact Apple loves
controlling [ __ ] this is one of the few
things Apple has done that isn't a
walled garden locked into Apple stuff
it's interesting cuz they're not even
monetizing it no and you know they they
have many different ways they could do
stuff or they could help but I don't
know why I don't know why they're not um
I think it's an oversight I think they
thought for the longest time that it was
just this thing that people did that was
big deal and then it's become so
enormous but they still have this map
this model they're operating under that
it's just they're just aggregating could
be I mean and what was interesting is
when they started off they immediately
started to highlight NPR program in
which I'm not I'm I'm grateful for I'm
WGBH in Boston did a lot with putting
their first programs making those
available as podcast but kind of the the
beauty of the the amateurism of podcasts
and got pushed down a little bit and it
was all BBC and PR yes yeah it's a
little too much for me the radio lab I
love radio lab but I know what you're
saying it's very produced it's very like
people answer questions for the guest
instead like you look caught in it so
what he said was this no why don't you
just let him say right well so this is
why you are The Tonight Show of our era
you have I feel like I'm playing the
Super Bowl here I mean if you see my my
DMS and my text messages people like
holy bluff Logan this is legendary they
go nuts and [ __ ] you know like an gotta
prep for the Super Bowl you know I've
got to get ready to slam this but you
have taken what you've really done the
opposite you've Zig to everyone zag and
you just have a conversation unedited
you're completely open type of
personality so instead of trying to rush
in and get the information example I am
I like
iliza shlesinger now when she was gonna
be on Kimmel like oh I'll stay up and
watch and watch that she was second
guessed which kind of sucks
because you get first guest you know and
then a bit and all that and there was
literally before she came on it was six
minutes of ads then a native ad in the
studio for Deez Nuts then another five
minutes if it was 12 minutes of
commercials and Schlessinger was on for
five minutes
buh-buh-buh not even a clip yep so
people are sick and tired of it I mean
no the existing media because of just
the the structure that's in place the
the ratings game
isn't really probably isn't really
reality but it's an approved methodology
people believe in those numbers that's
still there but there's a reason why you
get tulsi gabbard and bernie sanders and
people want to come on your show because
you speak to an entire generation my
daughter like holy [ __ ] my friends are
all time that you can be unbroken she
never never talks to me about any of
that stuff's like but you're okay okay
this is a little different that's also
yes well it's not like you don't know it
I mean this it's weird it's I dunno but
it's weird why do you think is why do
you say it's weird I was just weird it's
weird well well it was never intended
there was no intention like starting it
from the beginning was just fun and then
I well this is cool and then once it got
like a certain amount of people there
was a point time where I started getting
guests so I was like you want to do my
podcast and you know right cool people
like Anthony Bourdain was one of the
first well I remember in the beginning
and I've always wanted to be on your
show I think we've tweeted you know
maybe seven years ago or something you
were in Austin but I always felt like
dudes doing some kind of pirate radio
out there you know it's like what is
this you know there's something cool
going on there you know you got all
these people around you and and the
community comics or comedians which do
you prefer either ones fine I don't
think it matters no Kay some people
sticklers for it and I always find them
to be annoying so what I liked so much
is that
comedians gravitated toward it and said
okay we can be funny and we can do stuff
that isn't necessarily our jokes that
are gonna get ripped off because that's
I think for the longest time comedians
would be like I don't want to be on the
internet not putting my [ __ ] out there
because people will steal my jokes yeah
and they'll steal my whole routine and
if anything you and comedians started to
really blanket the landscape and show
you know what could be done with this
and the fact that everyone could just
kind of you know receive it on their on
their phone was fantastic we kind of
created a real organic Network that's
one of the things that we all kind of
talked about it that networks if you
think of a network like NBC or whatever
you think of its it's a controlled
network with executives and shareholders
and then there's advertised
yeah there's all these different
standards that you have to apply to the
salat agenda right exactly but everyone
we're on the network together we're on
Tuesday at 8:00 and these guys are on
Thursday at 7:00 and then all that so I
made that same mistake thinking that I
could build a podcast network and run it
kind of like like a hybrid network
record company mm-hmm
and raised a lot of money to do it too
first mistake is that the VC guys they
wanted us to be in San Francisco who
builds a media company in San Francisco
but okay it just doesn't work for a
number of reasons but the main one is
the advertising model is just not built
for this an advertiser wants to know and
I'm talking real advertise I'm not
talking you know underwear and
mattresses and and Squarespace we're
talking automotive pharmaceutical you
know still have Telecom these are the
real that's where the real money is they
want to know exactly what they're going
to be advertised on and if it's if they
don't know what it is they want no part
of it especially now as we have canceled
culture through social networking they
want no part of it so it's just not
going to be spectacular the way you know
something you're not gonna take those
advertisers away what I meant by a
network is not that no I know but that's
what I'm saying is like I tried to build
the contain Network failed in my mind
hey I mean people made money and
everything the investors didn't make
money but I tried to do that all things
they're still trying it it's just it's
not that profitable and it's also the
ones that are successful or successful
and the other ones aren't and like the
idea that they're all sharing revenue
it's like okay you kind of eat with you
kill so what you what you're trying to
say here about the ad hoc network he's
totally the way to go what I'm saying is
it's just that we didn't even think
about it we just were supporting each
other yeah comedians always suffered
from famine syndrome because there was
only a few shows on television and we
were all trying to be on a sitcom or you
were all trying to be the host of a
late-night show and there's only a
handful though I'm sure everyone wanted
to be that so that famine mentality was
like it created a lot of weird animosity
and competition between comedians
then somewhere along the line the
internet came along and then YouTube
videos started making people famous and
then podcast started making people
famous and then we all realize like the
old model of like hey if you do Leno you
can't do Letterman like there was a lot
of that nonsense back course of course
that shit's out the window now everybody
does everybody's show like bill burr
does mine I do his we all do each other
I'll do Joey Diaz he'll do mine we're
all friends and what happens is I hear
bill burr on your on your show and I'm
like oh [ __ ] he's got a podcast yeah in
Monday morning podcast boom subscribe
Joey Diaz not necessarily my kind of guy
but yeah he's off the hook his own
podcast is kind of fun so you are either
way kind of like a mothership the rising
tide lifts all boats that's that's how
we think about it how how capitalist oh
yeah but it's not even that way it's
just like everybody gets to do well it's
not that you know we're thinking of it
in terms of an industry at all it's
really just fun it just happens to be
profitable but the way we started it out
with no thought whatsoever of it ever
being profitable that's why I became
what it is because it was all like doing
giant bong hits and hitting all this
vaporizer and literally not even knowing
what you're talking about while you're
talking half the time and having fun
with it was part of the appeal because
half its everybody wants to be at the
party yeah that's even that's why radio
stations do remote broadcasts you know
this white top 40 stations go to Popeyes
yeah hey we're here this morning
everybody right everyone wants to be
part of it and if you're actually
partying yeah I mean that's that's what
people love of course yeah we do these
podcasts called fight companions and
then as some of our most popular ever
yeah and we'll watch fights and drink
and smoke weed while the fights are
going on and their madness their did
they become total chaos yes and those
are some of the most popular projects
shout-out to Ryan my dance instructor
who's a huge fan your us sir well my
wife and I we yeah yeah of course yeah
it's part of my workout regimen it is
worth a human
we'll do a double lesson
this has always been my dream and you
know so finally I found a woman who this
it's really do dancehall have you ever
dance ballroom dance but I did have to
take dance lessons for this movie
zookeeper that I did a few years always
with the Kevin Kevin Kevin James yeah
yeah they had a whole dance scene where
those like weeks like that movie me and
Leslie so it is the man leads the woman
it is a very traditional role in dancing
you know or if you have two women
dancing one of them has to be the lead
but in this case and the woman has to
give in to it and it is for both of us
we find it you know just for being
together and I'm leading she's following
it's a total trust thing there's all
this interaction you have which is
almost found upon in today's society you
know what the man is actually even me
saying this all your leading oh you're
leading I'm leading it's you know it's
called leading but we do an hour and a
half like a double lesson I'm sweating
now yeah I'm all your muscles everything
and just look at them on Dancing with
the Stars these funds are cut it's hard
you know I talked to Chuck Liddell who
is the UFC light heavyweight champion he
told me that dance with the Stars when
the hardest things he ever did I believe
hearing for it I believe it yeah it's
hard yeah it's real Joe Rogan says
Dancing's real a bumper sticker it's a
difficult thing to do and the cool thing
is you can do it anywhere yes we want to
get to that we've only just started
couple months but we want to get to the
part where we can just go into a place
and just dance oh look at that yeah
that's cool that's a it's I I'm a big
believer in learning things and liking
lessons and just does something you suck
at just try it so I got my ham radio
license academically I'm a piece of [ __ ]
and I barely made it through high school
I dropped out of college in two months
like this is not for me this is like me
I learned how to fly helicopters and
airplanes so I've gotten all these these
things and that's all not that I really
fly that much anymore does helicopters I
know I know I heard that
flew me around downtown LA yeah and then
Rob being 4422 he doesn't have his own
he was using one of the ones that this
helicopter company right it was a
four-seater two-seater it was a force
okay
Robinson 44 yeah that's what I trained
in I was owned two helicopters really I
had a helicopter company whoa yeah in
Texas you could shoot pigs out of him
yes but never seen though this was in in
the in the Netherlands yeah no believe
me I've been invited I'm sure yeah I
don't like I don't like that idea well
it's a very unfair idea but also they
have to do something like there's other
things that are problems the pigs are
problem but it is like to me it's like
haha not problem is that's the problem
right why is that the problem is the
joking around about it while while death
is happening it's a disturbing in very
unwinnable situation because the feral
hog problem is so big particularly in
Texas that you know they lose millions
of dollars in crops every year yeah many
minutes of real problems just I just
can't get into 300 bucks an hour
helicopter you know just shoot it yeah
out of the window yeah it's a lot of
food though it does make a lot of food
they donate the food I have never shot a
living thing I've I have I've gone I
I've shot a lot of guns meat oh yeah oh
hell yeah yeah yeah I mean all pigs are
a good place to start there's a it's a
place that does oryx okay and if you
ever had Oryx no I have no all I heard
oh my god it's so good they back so they
as a conservation in Texas mm-hmm and
it's actually more Oryx and Texas than
in Africa I believe that's true you know
because they're you know they're they're
really managing them you can go there
you can you know hunt and shoot them and
then they'll do they'll dress the whole
thing for you if you want you can do it
yourself that part's not for me I don't
know I just like I just don't think I
can if I if I had to no problem but now
I don't have to right yeah no I get it
man I got it it's not for everybody you
have you ever shot something yeah yeah I
hunt yeah an arrow right okay that's a
whole different level
yeah it's well that this is my first
animal ever shot that deer I shot on a
TV show called meat-eater and I got
hooked right after you because I was
that was either gonna become a
vegetarian or I was gonna become a
hunter right seeing too many of those
PETA video
you dress them you did all that yeah I
got a buddy who does that Scott yeah in
Austin when I go when I help go elk
hunting will dress it in the field and
quarter but then I'll send it to a
butcher to get it chopped up right
different cuts Vietnam I love meat
nothing wrong yeah it's um I understand
what you're saying like to pull the
trigger and to be there when an animal
dies it's intense but it also makes you
realize what you're doing when you're
eating meat absolutely yeah and I think
just knowing this I'm cognizant of it
and I I don't bless my food but I think
about it like yeah thanks man
well thanks thanks madam and I was in
Utah last September and I shot this elk
not only do these guys pray for the elk
everyone takes their hat off but they
actually take a wad of grass that the
elk eat and they make like a bundle of
it and they put it down on the elk
carcass when we were done cleaning the
elk so after the the bare bones of the
elk after the meats removed they put
this this thing down they take the hats
off it was pretty serious right these
guides they do it with every every elk
that dies yeah yeah cuz it's you know
it's a part of their livelihood but it's
also their majestic there there and
there
- they're delicious beautiful lamb and
this yeah and they're so special they're
so interesting like if I could just eat
elk for the rest of my life I'd be happy
doing that reindeer who tried reindeer
no caribou okay reindeer and I had some
reindeer they have is a restaurant and
then a buddy of mine worked at Nokia at
the time and they bring you a picture
this is it and he's alive you're like I
feel is Rudolph and then Darius so they
write before they serve it I don't know
that but they they do show you you know
this is the one you're eating right here
Wow yeah fantastic fantastic neat yeah
it's caribou is a very prized meat yeah
and they're they're amazing animals too
and they they have these huge herds of
them and I went to the North Pole and I
saw just tons of him tons him up there
do you know how story with them and
psychedelics with caribou yeah
no but I'm interested okay caribou or
are connected to a mushroom called the
Amanita muscaria mushroom they're
addicted to this mushroom they eat it
constantly
they've actually been known when people
do psychedelic ceremonies in the
go outside of their yurts to pee
terrible will knock them over to try to
get to their urine because their urine
is rich with the smell of this this
mushroom yeah they eat it constantly
hence it's a psychedelic mushroom the
flying reindeer it gets crazier the
connection between Santa Claus and
reindeers is very strange
the connection between Santa Claus in
this mushroom is also very strange the
mushroom looks like Santa Claus it's red
and white it also shows up under pine
trees it has a micro riser relationship
with coniferous trees so when it rains
the the mushrooms will pop up under
these trees so these bright packages
that look like it was under the tree
exactly that is what they look like
under trees wait boom gets crazier to
dry them off the shamans would pick them
and then put them in the pine that could
put that photo up against round thanks
me put them in the pine needles to dry
them off so just like like balls riding
in the trees right right and ornaments
and a Christmas tree well we still put
pine needles in the pine cones and yes
exactly and and balls those bright
colored balls they think the origin of
that was those things also Santa Claus
came down the Christmas tree and when or
excuse me when they were discouraging
these shamanic rituals people had to
sneak into people's houses to perform
them on one of the ways they did that
was to climb down through the chimney so
the shock dropped down to the chimney
with the bag of mushrooms and then they
would all have these ceremonies and when
these ceremonies were forbidden that's
how they how they got around it yeah
it's a the relationship between Santa
Claus and Christmas and this mushroom is
very strange and there's tons of
articles also almost all of the old
Christmas cards had the Amanita muscaria
mushroom on it and elves also the elves
that connect I'm gonna tell about that
he's he collects he's an archivist he
collects old Christmas cards oh hey I'll
bet she has some of those find old
Christmas cards with mushrooms just
thousands of them I've never done
mushrooms
what does dmt no no no thank you I don't
smoke we view it okay and I did DMT and
enjoyed it very very much that's a
that's a wild one huh
twice see look at these old old
Christmas find some some ones that show
like merry look at that one right there
in the middle yeah there you go see that
one
Merry Christmas trip your balls off kids
now look they all have mushrooms oh my
god in the early 1900s when they were
making these in the even in the 1800's
people are just more connected to the
origins of these stories sure and over
time we've kind of lost that
commercialized it into all kinds of but
it's always the Amanita muscaria if you
look at these yeah the monster of course
it's always that one mushroom that looks
like Santa Claus Wow
yeah it's a weird mushroom though that
was a complicated mushroom because it
varies genetically and also varies
geographically and also vary seasonally
I've never I've done it before but I
never had a good reaction out of it I
did it with my friend Stanhope and Doug
and I did and we weren't feeling it and
then we had some other mushrooms we
brought some psilocybin mushrooms we
threw them into the party and then then
we took off I'm not into eating any
drugs no I like smoke and flour that's
about it okay I grew up in Amsterdam
that made it kind of easy yeah I'm sure
yeah it's um
yeah it's it's tricky especially you
don't know what you're getting mm-hmm
you know but mushrooms are pretty pretty
standard once you've done it a few times
you know what you know what you're
getting into but that that mushroom and
Christmas is so it's very anyway the
caribou which is pull Santa's reindeer
pull the sled right well they're flying
cuz they're tripping their balls off
they're high as [ __ ] Wow yeah the more
you know yeah I mean that's probably the
reason why those reindeer are addicted
to that mushroom they favor it they love
it
yeah that's it's a weird one story that
mushroom also is a weird one in that
when people take it they trip and then
to really enhance their trip they drink
their urine because apparently the the
in the urine contains like your body
filters out you get an ex super blast
exactly yeah fantastic
weird stuff I'm trying to cut back on
drinking my pee though yeah it's good
bit it's just it's unsightly that's
socially so unacceptable you know just
like what the hell you doing ker
yeah um but anyway carob I've never had
it but I've heard it's delicious and
I've had a bunch of different kinds of
deer access to yours probably the
favorite that's that's really delicious
that's another one is a weird it's a
weird deer because it's an invasive
species in Texas in the backyard here in
your backyard no no I got deer oh really
yeah I don't know a white-tailed deer I
have no idea do they have white spots
all over their bodies and weird horns I
don't like that
that's a mule deer you probably like
many of those probably whitetail I don't
know they hiss [ __ ] oh yeah that's the
girls usually they're letting the men
know that there's yeah danger here yeah
and you know they just walked right
through the backyard walk onto the
street they're all in and we live in a
cul-de-sac they're all over the place
whatever okay yeah yes what happens when
there's no predators it's becomes a real
issue people slam their cars into them I
have a buddy who lives in Iowa and you
can't even went to the rut like in
November you can't even drive yeah just
a cross on the road everywhere
everywhere you going you better be going
20 miles an hour start out with a boner
we don't know what they're doing because
the male's lives $30 marbled basically
rodents you know just kind of well to
hell they're not that wise so I don't
feed him just go away
yeah that's smart keeping going move on
people yeah Butler apples or something
in your backyard
no comes don't have any of that least
you guys don't have bears that's when it
really is a pain in the ass people got
coyotes now though I bet you do yeah so
a couple of those walking through the
yard yeah and they're you know I have no
pets so yeah we've lost pets I used to
have someone I used to have so many pets
I had everything yeah dogs cats goats
horses without them I do yeah I do it's
just you don't really realize it until
you know you you're closing the sliding
door you're opening it up and you're not
thinking [ __ ] Yeah right if someone
gonna get out you know very free that's
a weird thing to always feel bad the
cats can't even go outside well they
can't go outside in Texas they'll get
eaten yeah but it's just sad that they
can't even go outside like what the [ __ ]
kind of life is that just living in a
little prison like a you know in a cage
yeah no I don't like goldfish I'm like
any of that goat so had a lot of goats
those are mean [ __ ] yeah that's
horses too I am I had a thing my
daughter had horses and like I had a
castle in the in Belgium we had and two
horses there you got a castle in Belgium
yeah I just have money no no I took my
company public in 96 called think new
ideas and it was one of the first
internet marketing advertising companies
and it was big we had 400 people it was
a big company why and yeah my buddy and
I we just worked out and we took it
public and back then it was like this is
before the real dot-com craze so we
raised twenty million dollars like holy
[ __ ] we couldn't believe it which is
nothing these days and after all the
lawyers never wanted taken their money
there was 15 million left and so we
started to build the business and what
we're talking about hassle you know
castle yeah so there was that and then
I'd also at the time someone had said I
did pretty well on the on the IPO and
I'm not crazy but you know okay there's
a you know I learned what dilution means
I learned that pretty quick
but I'd invested $50,000 in some company
and then I'd in 2000 just before 2000
moved to Amsterdam move back to the
Netherlands and the bank called me said
you sitting down yeah what's up so
remember that company you invested in I
said yeah well it went public it was
asked Jeeves and you know have 65
million dollars I'm like on paper
I'm paper Joe so lock up you couldn't
sell any of it you know all this stuff
so I did get some out but you know
basically wrote it down to wallpaper you
can't sell it well if you're an insider
right you you lock up your shares it's a
it's an SEC regulation so you can't sell
for them I think the it's negotiable but
it's it's it's so the other investors
who come in won't be left holding the
bag so you know going to do the IPO and
then all the insiders sell their shares
and everyone who just bought at the IPO
then all their [ __ ] goes down in value
it got screwed so you have to there's a
lock-up typically six months or 12
months or 18 months
and through some back ended way out the
hell was going on our bankers do it with
swapping stuff and promises and
derivatives they were able to get some
money out for me that I spent on
helicopters and all kinds of fun stuff
I've enjoyed the money yeah that's
definitely glad I got the podcasting
thing left so how'd you get back to
Austin well I so I had the company in
San Francisco this is a different
company the podcast company and I was
going I was living in London at the time
so I lived there for five years
damn you're an international traveler I
have lived in a couple places and was
going back and forth
San Francisco London and there was a
breakup between me and my wife and we
got divorced and so I stayed in San
Francisco and then moved to California
to Los Angeles for about a year I always
want to live in LA lives in the hills
over like Highland and it just didn't
work for me you know I was doing
basically the podcast and that shows me
I'm like 1213 years ago and I don't know
it's just maybe it was that area but I
really had nowhere else to go and if I
wanted to go somewhere I'm just sitting
in traffic all day it's like if I want
to go the beach no I was with a woman at
the time who was an actress I never I
never marry an actress man bad I was
warned so she wanted to be in that
general area so it just wasn't working
for me
and then I did a tour from Virginia down
to Florida the Gulf Coast for the show
with an RV doing the show from the RV
meeting people doing meetups and it was
it was just around the time when the you
had the the BP oil spill in in the Gulf
and so people really depressed and it
was all messy and just not was not a
good vibe and I was gonna go straight up
to Chicago and a buddy of mine
Greg Lally who was one of the true last
independent record promoters who had
known from San Francisco and he knew
from Chicago back from the radio days
and he said Oh Adam come to Austin
you'll love it comes to come to us who
stay at my place coming
like nah man I'd never really been to
Texas you know just like it doesn't
really interest me I'm just gonna go up
to Chicago and just kept pushing and
pushing us from driving up and then he
says or I thought to myself
Greg is flamboyantly gay single dad
adopted a kid from Ukraine and if he's
in Texas and he's still alive
it can't be that bad maybe it's just
Austin I don't know so I visit him and
we did a meet-up and this is in the
summer so it's about 112 degrees but you
know that Austin heat is not too humid
it's it's doable and there were 30 33
people at the Meetup and they were all
happy and proud of their city and proud
of their state and they loved what was
just it was so much good energy
particularly after it just came from the
Gulf and one young woman her purse fell
on the ground
and out rolled a fresh pair of
Underpants
and a handgun I'm like Texas moved there
three months later really I've been
there ten years now Wow it has grown
though oh my god it's changing this talk
about it too much I mean I've lived in
my wife Tina knives we got married in in
May we bought a house together the South
East Austin but we were living downtown
right downtown I had a place there and
we moved into an apartment together
and we just saw it happening it really
started with the with the scooters
that's really what started to mess up
Austin because they just overnight it's
like what the [ __ ] is this and just
they're everywhere and you mean
Austin already been trying to create a
bike vibe with bike paths and you know
just all the stuff which is ludicrous
and I grew up riding bicycles and it
takes maybe 50 years before everyone is
accustomed to bicycle traffic you know
it's not just something that's built in
I turn right around the corner I still
look look at my right mirror I look
there so that make sure there's not a
bike next to me and just built-in though
people don't do that so people always
getting hit and then these scooters pop
up and it's just mayhem yeah
everywhere there on the sidewalks there
mowing people down people are it's nuts
they go fast to just may go very fast
they go merry guys he's got a souped up
one hmm how fast is that [ __ ] go like
50 25 back we'll see hey this one's a
good 50 oh yeah oh I've seen him jacked
up doing 50 oh my sure thing
you're dead yeah well no there's that
yeah you going down at fit he's 25 is
already pretty fast he flies yeah I
think most of them do about 15 15 17
miles is juicy but what I noticed is
because all the Silicon Valley companies
are opening up offices in Texas a lot of
them in Austin and that's where they put
the the human resource heavy stuff so
not the top programmers this is helpdesk
this is the people who review the
YouTube videos so you know they're
already kind of whack because they're
watching nothing but death and
destruction and fucked-up [ __ ] all day
long they don't really have a connection
to the city they're kind of like I'm
here for a couple years and I'll go move
somewhere else
so they don't care and they're on the
scooters so they don't really care about
the city about the whole vibe like
whatever drive around and that's become
increasingly more Austin has some other
problems now we're kind of following
what what California world San Francisco
Los Angeles Portland Seattle you know
we're following the let people camp
everywhere are things that's become a
real problem and it's crazy here you
know it's based upon it all comes from a
lawsuit in Boise Idaho and that's where
this started where and the first we went
through the Fifth Circuit and the Ninth
Circuit Court there was an appeal that
said you cannot move people who are
camping without having a suitable place
for them to stay that you can offer them
because then it's a violation of the
Eighth Amendment under cruel and unusual
punishment that's why and that's what
Austin's a well until that solved it's
cruel and unusual punishment to move
someone who's homeless or not move
someone who's camping if you can't offer
them adequate housing so these people
are just camping on sidewalk
they're just like they do here is that
the underpasses medians you know the
underpasses yeah it's crazy and so it's
this weird easel situation yeah this
really started well they were they
lifted the camp the no camping mat
lifted it so it was not a problem then
they said well we're gonna let anyone
camp and it went nuts and all of a
sudden downtown was just filled with
people lay in camp and everywhere then
they went oh this is not gonna work
mayor adler and city council so okay
we'll ban it in the just in downtown
which is pretty much where the mayor
lives you know the W Hotel this that you
can't no camping in front of City Hall
but we have a we're university town so
you've got UT and it's just there's this
whole you know like half of a like a
semicircle of camping and just mayhem
right on the on the outskirts of the
campus and you know kids are afraid you
know like nothing to get in harassed
we have squeegee guys dude I drove into
New York every single day from Jersey in
89 90 and near the squeegee guys were a
huge problem and then they were gone I
think Giuliani like threw him in the
East River or something but and now
they're back in New York it's like this
is not not a good thing yeah how do you
fix that though the people are worried
about the cruelty in fixing oh there you
go you know that's the problem it's like
you it's a you have you almost have to
be cruel to stop that no no how do you
stop well you have to engineer what are
we talking about not everyone who is
squeegeeing and loitering and and
soliciting is homeless right or you know
it's not necessarily something that they
didn't choose a lot of people choose a
vagrant lifestyle the tons of it
particularly in warmer climates like
here and I do a lot for the homeless
problem in Austin as much as I can and
none of it is sanctioned by the city
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] build affordable
housing we'll get a hotel and we'll turn
that in here it's like Oh a slum hotel
okay great
the number one reason people become
homeless is catastrophic loss of family
that's the number one reason someone
dies you know this that and then just
it's
downhill from there and before you know
it you're out on the streets very
difficult to rebound from that kind of
thing
and so people need community everybody
needs community so where do they find
the community under the bridge that's
where the community is and the community
is transactional it's drugs you know
it's whatever you did that's a community
it's not a healthy one but it's a
community there's actually a great
project in Austin called mobile loaves &
Fishes community first village started
by this guy who was in construction and
he just put down a whole bunch of tiny
homes and people who are if you're
homeless you can go there and you can
live in a tiny home but you rent it and
there are some you know some
prerequisites but you don't have to be
you know necessarily drug free because
it's your homes you can do whatever you
want in your home but it's like $200 or
$250 a month most people if they do the
paperwork they can get Social Security
or disability which will cover that they
still have to you know either work there
in the community garden to feed
themselves at different you know like a
Auto Detailing got all this different
stuff but there's no police saying it's
not you know this or this
I think there's five hundred people
there now and it's working out
fantastically well that's cool because
they have community now that you can
outside-the-box to lose totally totally
gets no money from the city because
there's a religious aspect to it you
know there's a ministry part so oh we
can't give money to that because you
know [ __ ] god nuts or whatever is but
it's really working extremely well
that's great when someone comes up with
something yeah you know I don't I mean
people should look at this Allen Graham
is a saint what he did and he lives
there he lives in a you know in a small
you know a small home on premises yeah
and if you go there he'll be happy to
show you around and you got all kinds of
cool stuff but just people are living
together he says so if Joel walks out in
the morning not you Joe but the other
Joe and he's got his dick hanging out
he's like instead of the neighbors
calling the cops
the neighbors Hey Joe what's going on
man let's sit down for a second let's
have a coffee let's see what's going on
pull your pants up you know let's sit
and a community right community first
village that's that's the answer but
that's not
the answer that you hear from your local
city council or your mayor's as always
we don't have affordable housing man
how's everything it's also there's a lot
of mental illness that's a job well of
course but there's a lot of people with
mental illness who have houses you know
it's true definitely it's a mental
illness and drug addiction but it really
starts with catastrophic loss of family
that's the number one reason people
become unhoused out here is this shift
was Jimmy would you say about four or
five years ago it really started kicking
in somewhere around then yeah somewhere
around four or five years ago you just
are to know that noticing like villages
of tents under underpasses
yeah and then I used to do Fear Factor
in downtown LA like right down street
from Skid Row which is an extraordinary
place if you've never seen Skid Row and
you drive by you go what this is real
like this is downtown Los Angeles and
you urine which is which they turn
beautiful by the way I mean that really
you know downtown LA became really nice
in some parts of yeah great yeah great
great infrastructure and everything but
the restaurants and cool really cool
apartment buildings and stuff it's an
interesting spot but then there's also
Skid Row yeah which is just you can't
believe the staggering numbers of people
that are just camped out yeah thousands
and thousands and thousands just a mass
like people coming out of a [ __ ]
stadium to see a game Adam Carolla said
it said it really well okay where I saw
him he said it's like no one wants to be
the bad guy no one no one want to say
okay this [ __ ] has to stop we got to do
something about that and it starts with
stopping whatever you're doing and
that's part of canceled culture yeah
people are afraid you know because if
canceled cultural is real if you have
something to lose like you have nothing
to lose I have nothing to lose they can
your your bulletproof to a degree I'm
bulletproof
you can cancel all you want you're not
taking away for me no advertisers I
don't have them you know the only the
people who listen can stop listening
that's the only thing that could happen
Iman attached your podcast for
advertisers
what we call it the value for value
system and when the Warrick and I
started the show 13 years ago it was
just him and I just you know talking on
skype I was in London he was
in San Francisco and we noticed that
because I'd like to read legislation
I'll read bills I'll read I was reading
the lisbon treaty which was kind of the
European it was supposed to be the
European Constitution which was voted
down by France the Netherlands and
Ireland and then the European Union went
no no no let's vote again you did it
wrong literally like revote and so okay
I guess we'll vote this way now guys and
then I was reading it like this is this
is not the way it's being portrayed on
television like Oh we'll have it won't
need a passport to go to other countries
will have the same money and I was
seeing [ __ ] in there that was way
different about you can incarcerate
people you can deadly force by the cops
would be legalized and none of this is
really what's what's happening over here
at the same time I read a book called
I'm just gonna give you the background
to get into the money part called legacy
of ashes by New York Times a writer
David Weiner I think and it was about
the CIA and my uncle appears in this
book multiple times my uncle Don Greg
who was big big guy in the CIA for a
long time and and I called him up said
they'd done have you read this he says
yes is it true he said yes pretty much
how I remember it
I'm like okay so whatever is on
television and radio is not at all
really what's going on or what has
happened and so they started becoming a
lot of work we're doing work and then we
said well we'll never get advertised we
know the war acts a radio guys and media
guys so we understand and understand
that all will never get advertisers
that'll never work so we'll just have to
ask people to send us money but why'd
you say you would never get advertisers
because it's too controversial adverse
adverts I mean yeah we can get some
advertisers but not the real advertisers
and what we talked about earlier and
there's no advertisers really going to
be interested and also how do you you
know what are your what are your ratings
what are your metrics what are your
numbers you know the certainly then the
questions well how do you know if
someone listen if it's just the download
I mean I can I'm sure you've gone
through all of this also we didn't want
to have a [ __ ] meeting yeah we'll
have a meeting with advertisers
I don't want to meet anymore no more
meetings so but we did something
different we said instead of saying send
us five bucks I don't work for tips
you don't work for tips instead of that
what is this show worth to you so you
just listen to us for a couple hours you
could have gone to the movies you know
if you took a date had some you had a
coke and popcorn fifty bucks was this
worth fifty bucks up to you and what we
discovered is that value is very
different some people will say that's
peers five dollars I love the show
someone else says here's $500 that's how
much I value the show someone else says
[ __ ] I'm gonna give you $1,000 that's
how much I value the show and we built
this model where we literally just say
what value does the show bring to you
and we thank people with the amounts
that they gave we're completely
transparent you could just sit there and
see what people are giving us and it
just became this whole interactive
feature where where we put levels in so
if you if you donate $200 you're an
associate executive producer just like
Hollywood the [ __ ] to say it's a real
$300 in executive producer and we do a
little mention in a different part of
the show for the executive producers and
you know they can read a note and
oftentimes it's it was usually something
about the show so they're cut that
bought into the conversation
specifically so it's not just a donation
segment it's content and we have like
you have lawyers doctors nurses teachers
college professors tons of military lots
of spooks and three-letter agency DC
it's also this kind of a spook agency
there's all kinds of crazy people who
really I think enjoy when we talk about
what they're doing and so they love to
let you know and then maybe anonymous
you know hey man don't mention my name
but you know here's and that just grew
and you know now 13 years later we're
feeding to families and we're very very
happy and that's all I do is you know
twice a week Sunday's Thursday's we have
a we do we do recorded live you know
do any post editing or anything sits in
and out is done and do you like the fact
that you just don't have any connection
to anyone other than your fans is ever
satisfying extremely satisfying I mean
it's it's not just fans we call them we
don't call them listeners fans they're
producers and everybody is a producer if
you see the amount of stuff that I get
in you know
so take coronavirus you know we've got a
lot of people who are very specified
that not just in epidemiology but in
finance who can you know give us all
these different insights and you put it
all together I'm really a professional
information manager and I've built a
whole bunch of systems specifically for
that I just get stuff coming in coming
in and we like to deconstruct the media
so we'll play anywhere from 30 to 50
little news clips in a three hour show
and then just deconstruct it you know
why is this being said what is what is
what is really behind this is it true
and you know then I spend a lot of time
researching that's really what I do I
just research and look at stuff and bang
it around look at this if I can from all
angles as much as possible and then
present it and it's often surprisingly
accurate Wow I I loved that idea of
calling them producers and I loved the
idea that you're not connected at all to
anyone other than your fans mm-hmm yeah
that's perfect
the producers Joe yeah that's the
producer I like it and then we and then
we started to I guess the correct term
would be game of Phi it so people start
saying hey man I've donated a thousand
dollars like totally like over whatever
that's fantastic we should reward these
people so we started to give them
knighthoods
why should the queen who I've met why
should the Queen of England be the only
one who can do that we can do
knighthoods they're just as good you get
a signet ring and some sealing wine yeah
yeah you get a real wing rings you'd
actually like close a letter with it yes
oh when drip the metal black people send
letters to us all the time they got
their meetups that people with their
rings like that's like edge of Honor
it's a little cult II it had it's a
little bit unavoidable there's a lot of
different elements I would say more like
a church which can also be a cult yeah
yeah you know it's not an evil cult in
fact it's a very healthy Colby now have
people are now doing meetups around the
world where they come together and you
know we have a no agenda meetups calm
people can schedule it and we got all
this that's another thing we have all
the infrastructure the entire show is
run by the producer so we have
independent architecture for our servers
all of that one run by void zero Serb M
rows they run it they do it you know out
of the love love and goodness of their
heart for the show of course they
receive titles etc for that we have an
art generator where every show we have
it has new art there'll be ten or twelve
different submissions it's kind of a
little contest you know to have new art
on every every new podcast is really
exciting when it shows up in the podcast
app it's something different
but we also have you know oh my god we
have search engines we have just all the
stuff that guys and gals have just built
for us and just kind of runs and it all
kind of fits together so we we would
never be able to make money with this if
we outsource the production you know
paid production we wouldn't make it and
I think it's very hard for anybody to do
that unless you're at a JRE scale which
is a little different I don't we don't
even know how many people listen we
don't know we don't [ __ ] care I just
don't know how many people is there's no
actual way to know there's no technical
way anyone telling you different is full
of [ __ ]
there's no way to know how many people
listened it's just not the Apple iPhone
app does have some statistics that you
can get but it's only iPhone statistics
you can kind of get an idea and you can
extrapolate out that's recent that they
have that meaning that you don't know
how many downloads really or you don't
know how many people I just count down
downloads but how many people listen to
you don't know it's and even then
there's a lot of network address
translation that you may not be counting
all the downloads it's just technically
not true unless you rig the listening
side which is kind of what Apple did and
have statistics there which no one has
there's no way to actually know who's
listening
but for us it's like can I pay the
mortgage okay great show that's it and
that is it's like killing and eating the
meat yourself mmm it's it's it's a
version of that and I love it we've
spawned a couple other shows that have
the same system Jen briny with
congressional dish I've started a new
one called mo facts which has the same
system ology it is so [ __ ] gratifying
it really I love it I love the people
who help us who produce stuff for us and
we'll go to a meet-up people you know
donate on the spot but they also love
just meeting together without us they're
all over that like leap day there must
have been 14 different meetups around
the world and I'm talking Israel
Australia England the Netherlands just
all over the world and they get together
to just be in a non triggering
environment so you can say whatever the
[ __ ] you want kind of like our show and
you know no one's gonna get triggered no
one's gonna get outraged and it's all
different kinds of walks of life and
they have one thing in common it's like
you know they think the media is kind of
full of [ __ ] and and they support the
show and they like those topics and and
you know but there's no it's just it's
small amygdalas man mmm that's cool
small amygdalas um it has been a weird
it must be it's been a weird ride for us
noticing how much more outraged people
get at things today than they did just a
few years ago and targeted outrage where
people just decide that you know they're
gonna start tacking you for something
that used to be normal to say like there
was a some of it is so ridiculous it's
crazy like there was a titania McGrath
had a that's a great cook Twitter
account yeah Andrew shoutout to Andrew
he's got a post there was a sign that
was hanging from a window in the UK that
it basically was the definition of a
woman it said
woman a female human being
noun right that's like the sign and then
all these people went crazy and we're
protesting and saying that it's a
transphobic dog-whistle which is that's
a new one right dog whistle has only
been around for like two years people
calling something that transphobia
homophobic or sexist dog whistle like
holy [ __ ] like you can't say anything
anymore well let's go back to the basics
yeah I was on the internet very early
1987 before the World Wide Web and you
may remember we had something called
Usenet groups yes and the Usenet groups
and the way it used to work because we
didn't really have a widely spread
internet back then except in
universities now I was on MTV and when I
saw the in I'm like holy [ __ ] I'm
emailing with kids my audience who were
not counted in the ratings by the way in
college audience don't count in the
Nielsen ratings at least didn't at the
time and they want something very
different from what MTV is playing so I
was like wow this is interesting so I
got into these Usenet groups and the way
that worked is you'd post something and
then overnight it would be copied all
around the internet and you had to
connect to a special server and you
pulled in the groups that you had
subscribed to and so really it was kind
of a it wasn't an immediate conversation
but he'd post something and then people
would reply back and I just kind of
jumped in two feet and immediately
fuck-you commercial MTV [ __ ] what are
you doing here [ __ ] off that you know
you're not supposed to quote like that
you're supposed to quote at the bottom
and the top and I was like whoa what's
going on and what that was is the minute
you have the opportunity for people to
say stuff anonymously they turn into
giant dick bags almost everybody this is
just an easier way to do it yeah now
we've made it so easy and with all the
little the you know the the the blips
and the blooms and the rewards that you
feel when something is posted or someone
it goes against you and it's like and
again I think amygdalas have swollen
because of this so then you get this
this you respond differently to what you
think is an attack and the attack read
it and you know this [ __ ] registers in
your brain as something really dangerous
I'm going to go back at them but they're
anonymous and that's the that's the
best thing then the blue checkmark
became a little more interesting which I
don't have and I tried to get one for a
long time they someone over there hates
me and now really oh yeah they wouldn't
know that's what it is they hate you
what else would it be
I've never gotten a blue checkmark I
don't want one now now it's me it's the
mark of the beast you got a blue
checkmark you know I'd be looking over
my shoulder man like so now that's
become kind of those those are the
people that now risk being d platform
because you have status and so it's fun
to bang against these people like the
[ __ ] this guy I'm gonna bang against him
so it's some human nature that is that
just exists within us like you know
it'll be really easier for me to go
online you know under whatever Twitter
handle that joe rogan you dick I
wouldn't say that to your face look at
you you know beat me the [ __ ] up so no
but people have no problem doing that
anonymous yeah they don't see you they
don't feel the when people look at you
in the eye and they act like an [ __ ]
like they feel you like what the [ __ ]
man it's like a natural human instinct
to not do that all the visual cues the
human interaction
yeah that's how we're supposed to talk
you know the book connection the lost
connections I think it's a Harare I
think it's a nice name lost connection
he dealt you that's the guy you should
have on your show he delves into the
same guy wrote sapiens maybe I don't
know what's his name Noah Harare Noah
you've all her re is that him look
applause get lost Kentucky Johann Hari
Johann Hart
yes oh that's their guy he's been on the
podcast how's he go hon been on the
podcast yes yes so that's right lost
connection twice right okay yeah I miss
that one that that human eyebrows well
it's not just for catching sweat
dripping off your off your brow you know
it's for communication yeah inquisitive
yeah you know all this stuff use all
these cues are not not there the deep
platforming is getting really
preposterous to four things you know
zoobi got D platformed he got kicked off
a Twitter this is crazy
who zubi zubi is a musician he's a
rapper from the UK who's been on the
podcast for I mean they do does
swear all right he's back on so they
suspended him temporarily but this is
why he got suspended
he's I forget he was having a discussion
online about something and someone said
I bet I you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about something to that
regard like I bet I sleep with more
women than you do to which he writes
okay dude Oh Oh transphobic I mean he
didn't know he said I have no idea who
that person was especially especially
the UK it's illegal the UK you cannot
transfer beside somebody and you can
actually get a visit from the cops we
even made posts about it like showing
how ambiguous the probably like you
couldn't figure out he didn't know if it
was a guy or a girl you just know
someone said that and he was like that's
a ridiculous thing to say I bet I sleep
with more woman than you so he goes okay
dude
right like what he's not even assaulting
the person and they decided by him
saying okay dude that is grounds for
being banned from Twitter temporarily
like well madness and then these people
are laughing about it and making light
of the fact they were able to do that
because it's a game right there of a
rock they see oh yeah they want to throw
that rock and they got him they worked
they got him kicked off temporarily but
that sends a weird signal to everyone
else because it makes you self censor
it's it's not healthy for anybody it's
also not really a sustainable business
model long term I mean Twitter the Nate
because of this the canceled culture
they said we're not gonna take any
political ad you know like that's why
Jack Dorsey's gonna get kicked out you
see that ad I mean to see that new thing
with a billionaire guy just bought 12
singer Paul singer it he is a huge part
of the Republican financial engine this
guy has been under it's very interesting
he's doing this now because he's an
activist investor and he's he's trying
to get three or four board seats he'll
get them cuz you know of the amount of
shares he's bought up like a billion at
least because he you know sees the
so-called bias against the right and he
wants to skew that back all of that is a
failed mission the advertisers
eventually want no part of this they
just don't want to have a part of it the
future is
some version of a federated system which
exists today Mastodon if you'd heard a
mascot for a second when you see the
advertisers don't want a part of it
would they don't want controversy any
controversy [ __ ] no they don't want
column they don't want organized attacks
or bands they don't want don't want to
be near it right they don't want to be
near it it hurts I mean that's why you
see quite the opposite you'll see
Proctor and Gamble and all these big you
know going way out virtual signaling as
much as they can like oh you know we're
all yeah you know Sports Illustrated's
gonna have four I think for the first
time on the swimsuit issue will have
large women I'm saying that because
that's what they are they're large women
it's difference a large still I am there
might be a time problem what are they
gonna do yeah yeah tutus
but and and I'm not saying that's good
or bad but but that they're being forced
to do this it's not an organic thing I
didn't you know I'm not really a Sports
Illustrated guy but I just don't know
was this something that the readers
wanted maybe I don't I doubt it so and
again it's not necessarily bad but
anything by force is yes I'll go broke
that's yeah just give it a chance and no
one's gonna buy that up that's it but
that's another thing that I like about
your show is you're you're a man you're
dude you're not afraid of it you're not
afraid to say it and I think it's very
healthy and I'm sure you get all kinds
of [ __ ] all the time from all kinds of
people for all kinds of crazy reasons
but it's important that we keep some of
this just alive I get a lot of support I
mean I'm sure it's something for some
[ __ ] but I get way more support than I
do [ __ ] yeah I'm a nice person I just
happened you're on a male and I think
it's okay to be a man and this the whole
toxic masculinity thing is so [ __ ]
ridiculous like no there's bad people
some of them are men there's bad women
too like Casey Anthony it's a bad woman
doesn't it's not a indictment against
all women and this idea that men and
masculine behavior is somehow somehow or
another negative let no negative people
are negative that's what it is that we
men just and this attack on men is so
stupid so it's to throwing
out the baby with the bathwater and so
what it is it's just dumb it's just and
it's dumb people that are doing it and
they're doing it in an articulate way
and in a passionate way and they're
using all their verbal skills to try to
argue it in a way that they seem to
think that it's justifiable but it's
basically a tribal thing and then what
you see is you see big corporations who
do if anything want to be on the right
side of history they will never go
against the mob of Queens you just don't
go and so and it's not even the film
effectuates it's not even less like it
wasn't very said that people are
supporting you 20% of the people not
supporting use a large number if they're
active and it's it's it's such a waste
of time
yeah so when are we smoking some weed
because I'm about ready now I will say
beware Mike Tourette's will get a
significantly worse but but that can be
entertaining since I was I was diagnosed
when I was seven I actually didn't know
about it until my dad passed in November
and was and my this one there's a little
one no that's not and and so he and my
sister you know was talking to him and
wanted to know a couple things and and
and she wrote up a little kind of like
report and I was reading like oh [ __ ]
yeah Adam was diagnosed at seven with
mild Tourette's like they never even
[ __ ] told me thank you they didn't
tell you no I've known it because I got
twitches and things and MTV was great
for me because the segments were like a
minute and a half I can control it for a
minute and a half but you know I'm
always like typically I can see out of
the corner of my eyes like not here but
okay
they got Joe on screen so I could do all
my things right what causes it no no one
knows [ __ ] firing in your brain does
anything comment well it's not no I mean
I'm sure there's some crazy-ass drugs
but I won't do that hmm and of course
well you seemed a very very mild version
of it and why would you [ __ ] with your
neuro chemist
it's Who I am yeah so I'm you know I'm
55 I don't give a [ __ ] anymore whoo it's
a part of me I'm just saying it up front
because it'd be like the [ __ ] is Kerry
doing yeah that's why that's why I love
radio I've always been a radio guy you
know I can be like taken away and like
no one sees me you know oftentimes if
I'm doing a long thing I mean I'll just
be like completely screwed my eyes shut
I know be into it and no one can see
that right well there's something
beautiful about audio-only I mean I've
really enjoyed doing audio and video
together on this show but there is
something pure to tobacco in this oh no
no no why do you want some anyway no
that's just no I stopped yeah that's why
I pulled that one out
we have blunts here which I like oh I do
I've never done a blunt I do one but see
how this goes I'll give you a couple
minutes and where's the black rifle
coffee I'm a got the term race he's got
something yeah I'd love some the tumeric
I'm just afraid my lips are gonna look
like
like I puked yeah I know it does but it
doesn't really show up really yeah not
on camera
it's a look you get a little bit of a
hue to your to your lips of the turmeric
but that stuff's delicious fantastic
yeah in the coffee with that Laird
Hamilton superfood blend it's very very
tasty yeah and you know it tastes good I
like the taste you're doing something
good for your body it's actually good
for you legitimately I tell you man
that's the best thing for my body it is
I don't know the inside of a doctor's
office or Hospital I mean I'm hanging
together from THC Texas is weird though
right you know it's medical no no no no
medical no nothing no it's free no no no
see legal Oh everything in medical
mmm-hmm goddamn it hmm Jesus Texas it's
not like well in Austin they've actually
haven't really decriminalized but
they're like the cops so I mean I really
can't get away with letting people steal
and Rob and do crazy [ __ ] on the street
you know it's like here in California
you can steal up to 950 dollars and then
also go busting people for weed so they
really got better things to do so
they're not really making a problem out
of it but but it's still but still Ely
someone wants to find a reason to arrest
you absolutely nuts then it becomes an
issue absolutely it's just sad the Texas
which is one of the most free places in
the world you'd have a [ __ ] giraffe
in your backyard you can't smoke a joint
but it'll change it's inevitable it'll
change it's interesting because you know
growing up in the net
Evelyn's where now I marijuana was never
legal it was just they called it o´clock
into custom which means we look the
other way and it's okay that's basically
and you know it was it was limited to
coffee shops where you can sell it
that's still kind of that way you're not
actually allowed to produce it but okay
the Netherland is a narco-state I mean
all your ecstasy comes from there oh
yeah that everything is shipped through
the Netherlands the Holies all the
techno of course it was the techno came
with its own drug Dutch kick boxers who
are famous from coming out to techno
music yeah like Holland don't know if
you know is like the the birthplace of
some of the great boxers of all time not
really a man well I knew all I knew some
MMA guys there's some MMA guys in
Holland but it's really famous for
kickbox okay I didn't know it was
kickboxing yeah I really don't know [ __ ]
about it but I do know that a lot of
guys there become very famous like the
greatest of all time there's like it's a
crazy pool of talent that came out of
Holland yeah yeah like well the Mon
deckers and Rob came in and Ernesto
Hoost and Peter Hertz like the names of
these Dutch guys it's all savage dutch
guys and everybody was like how holland
like what what's happening over there
it's a is a very interesting country I'm
very glad I grew up there because it
gave me a world view I think that you
know is incomparable so the drugs has
never been a problem you could walk into
a bar at 13 look like you were 15 that's
changed now look like you were 15 you
could drink drink you know beards order
a beer how old you have to be the drink
well now they've changed it to 18 21
depending on where you are but it used
to be 16 kind of yeah it was very loose
I mean I have once the EU came into play
and they had to harmonize and become the
same as all the countries around it
which is not actually true because
Portugal decriminalized everything yeah
they decriminalized I think maybe 15
years ago and yeah spectacular results
but you can't really sell it but you can
get a prescription for almost everything
including heroin so they've they've
changed kind of that people have a
really hard time with that but hey look
we're not putting a dent in Harrell
folks now it's it's going the other way
it's going I mean when I was a kid I
never thought we'd have a heroin uptick
in this country when I was a kid
everybody thought of heroin is the stuff
that killed Jimi Hendrix and stay the
[ __ ] away from it people overdosed and
then they died once you start shooting a
needle boy
you [ __ ] up like don't go that I could
never even imagine putting a needle in
your in your arm that was like not even
imaginable it is the worst PR
representation of all time it's killed
some of our greatest rock stars right
Janis Joplin dead all these people Kurt
Cobain commits suicide had a problem
with heroin classically lead singer of
Alex and chains Elaine Staley right
heroin so many guys yeah and the guys
who kicked it who come back from it will
tell you Jesus Christ I was in Satan's
lap like he had a grip on me I could not
get free yeah and meanwhile it's got an
uptick so what's the solution the
solution is clearly not business as
usual that's like the devil you know
what does that expression the definition
of insanity doing the same thing over
and over getting a different result yeah
we know now that we have a problem well
I don't know if legalizing it is the the
only way to fix it
but to make it illegal you're just
propping up organized crime that's all
you're doing you're not stopping people
from doing it because these people
there's a giant percentage of them that
are doing stuff that a pharmaceutical
company made that they got illegally now
they're selling Italy right they've
become drug dealers whether it's the
cartels or or other povich oh you know
we had the financial crash in 2008 yeah
I don't think the trillions that we put
in really saved us I think the drug
trade in general was the only thing that
kept the economy running at the time I
mean this is so big the money in drugs
is so astronomical it's you don't even
you can't even fathom how big it is it's
a lot in yeah so many industries pale in
comparison
I mean h8a HSBC was literally you know
laundering the money from Mexico with
drug dealers just coming up on the
Mexican side throwing millions of
dollars a day into the deposit and got
you know pushed out the other way into
the legal
James Comey was running that at the
Jesus James he he was well aware it's
just nuts how much money is involved in
it and how many people look away you
know people are trying to stop different
flavored tobacco smoke I see you're a
vapor
well that that I actually look into that
very very deeply this was that the
tobacco industry had a problem the
problem was this I kicked cigarettes
with this because it's just you know you
can have nicotine in it or not but you
know it's not and if you had any health
consequences from using that thing zero
keep hearing about people getting lung
issues well okay so a couple things
happen the lung issues and I don't know
who you know personally but there was
this still know anybody person there was
a scare and the scare killed a couple of
people like ten people and what it
turned out was that was people who had
vaped THC cartridges and some the people
who put that you buy your THC cartridge
from a dispensary here it's actually
packaged by somebody else not by that
person so you have you know King world
or whatever these different you know
that's kind of a reputable brand but
it's packaged somewhere else that means
putting it you know putting the stuff in
and they put in some vitamin E acetate
and that just kind of like created a wet
you know heat that up and became a web
of some [ __ ] inside your lung and [ __ ]
you up so that's a man thing but that
nothing to do with vaping nicotine with
it with the typical chemicals that you
get from reputable companies I asked you
this is the the vaping from marijuana
what their process is more problematic
than vaping of tobacco well it certainly
was in that case because I just someone
so change the formula then you need to
have some some oil in there and want to
keep it you know liquid and for to you
know just for it to be able to go into
the vape and not the issue was actually
vitamin E oil yes yes and and so that
stopped of course somewhere someone did
something shitty and that happened you
know a really high guy actually said
this to me once he he told me that he
uses organic MCT oil for his vapes and
he was like handing me his video like
problem not suck on your vape I don't
even know you you could be a crazy
person you could be liquid DMT vapes
they have DMT
vapes now that's somebody hands you a
vape pen you might be going into orbit
for 20 minutes yeah for 20 minutes
before you're driving oh you know I've
flown a helicopter high on DMT no non
weed oh that's a dead man yeah with an
instructor you know he wanted to see how
I did it and it was perfect yeah I play
pool which is a very sensitive thing not
quite the same death by helicopter but
you're controlling the rotations of a
ball it's very literally the amount of
effort you put if you like you watch a
good player the amount of effort they
put really accurately depicts how many
revolutions of the cube I'm sure yeah
and after it's colliding with the object
ball and you get more sensitive to that
when you're high yeah jiu-jitsu is
another one a lot of people do jiu-jitsu
really yep and it's really really really
common guys smoked out in the parking
lot and then go roll it's really common
well that was I did the most perfect
landing ever
when I when I super into it oh and it's
very small input the helicopter you've
seen it yeah yeah anyway so the tobacco
industry had a real issue and that it
also comes back to the states because
there's this Master Agreement that was
put in place decades ago that tobacco
companies would pay a percentage of
their sales to all states to as a pre
compensation for whatever [ __ ] up [ __ ]
people get from smoking tobacco and all
these states wrote big bonds against
that money and so when the income from
the tobacco companies was decreasing
significantly because of vaping all of a
sudden the states are going especially
this one what the [ __ ] we have these
bond these bonds are gonna you know
become go bust that's you know when you
have your your state bond go bust you
know this is a real problem it's a
financial issue states and cities and
everything go broke so everyone had an
incentive to get rid of vaping and get
people back on tobacco
so they Altria bought Jul the the the
main that's what I mean this isn't this
is you know hardcore this is you know
got a battery it's all technical you get
to babe juice do
is a prepackaged product kids were
buying it like what's the benefit of
that over a jewel you can control how
much does it look like dragons and you
can you can put whatever you wanted it
not just limited by what jewel wants to
sell you so rifle coffee in the house
it comes with nice
the mugs yours to keep that mug I want
one of yours though you have a mug do
you make a no agenda box oh no agenda
shop comm which we don't run yeah these
got in they just send it donation from
time to time you can get mugs and
t-shirts and really just sell your [ __ ]
no no yeah so what they do is they they
go to the heart generator they get
images off of that then they put it on
t-shirts mugs hats whatever they sell it
give a third to the artist they keep a
third and they eventually give us some
money okay but you know it's we've
always said nope just do whatever you
want I'm careful we don't care it's a
kismet kismet karatsu I mean that's a
better word I don't know what either one
of those mean do you know those I don't
know either just sounds what does it
mean that's like something Larry Ellison
would say isn't curette to when two
companies agree in like Japan to do some
kind of you know business together with
like without a contract yeah those are
nice contracts verbal ones from PVD
trust your sir yeah it's like glad we
got together to do this it's way overdue
mmm way overdue for sure but those are
good relationships when you have a
relationship with someone you don't have
any paperwork just like each other
Devore I can i you know we eventually
had to you know do an LLC because the
the the IRS was going I don't understand
you know people send in checks that do
PayPal you know give cash so we have you
know all and they're just like you just
make a little simple or can we just
cutting it down the middle cuz you know
there's no one else involved yeah and
but otherwise we just had a handshake
you know for for a decade you know it's
like you didn't ask me to oh is this my
release yeah yeah you didn't ask me to
release the [ __ ]
okay Wow look at this whole thing here
we made that bit just in case because
you don't want to get sued but yeah we
can you know this is a weird world yeah
particularly well you got celebrity
guests on yeah this the only thing I
have to be careful about is slander I
guess yeah anyway back to that because
you like this story okay so it's a
tobacco States everyone skied up they
buy jewel for 18 billion dollars they
buy it as a write-off they want to get
this company out of the market then they
go to the FDA and they start all this
[ __ ] about flavors flavors flavors
flavors you saw it everywhere it was
massive it was a perfect storm we got 10
people dying from vaping something
completely unrelated but vaping East
cigarettes he had an e-cigarette he died
it was actually yeah he vape but he vape
tab add THC cartridge and you know got a
severe problem so you know how the media
plays that and then just kept on
spinning spinning there's like well we
have to stop the children and the way
you stop it is by taking away the
flavors because children they want
flavors that's what the problem is so
that [ __ ] jewel over and actually Altria
who used to they bought philip morris
basically so it's the biggest tobacco
company they start they already wrote
down half of it
just taking the [ __ ] l on it they
want to get rid of it because in the
wings they had their competing products
which is i qos i quit ordinary smoking
small I capital Q OS and it heats
tobacco so it's a it looks like a vape
pen it has though but it actually runs
on tobacco and it doesn't burn it it
heats it up has whatever it's some kind
of mechanism in the filter you inhale
and it's almost there dream which is the
smokeless cigarette very close to it but
most importantly it's not a nicotine
synthetic nicotine it is tobacco product
which is their business and they've got
they really ratcheted this up so high
that they got Trump involved and Trump
actually with melania they did a thing
with Alex SR the Health and Human
Services Secretary he said well you know
B this vaping is very dangerous we have
a kid
actually was one of those moments where
everyone loves to jump on Trump
he said Melania has a kid you know he
forgot to say it was his whatever it was
and now he's actually been overheard
saying I wish I'd never gotten involved
in that [ __ ] thing because he figured
it out he figured out was a huge scam
that the bill has been stopped but now
they're still trying to push through a
bill that will help the tobacco
companies even more by outlawing any
type of flavored cigarettes or juice
liquid or what they just want to get rid
of it so it's really like who killed the
electric car it's exactly that and they
just go look at it now I QoS they're
launching there's new stories today that
say oh my god it's the saving grace we
have the new product we've all been
waiting for it right at the moment that
vaping it's going to kill you it's
hooking children because of flavors so
do you think they're they're hiring
people to write news stories and the
news organizations are picking you up
because they're being told to just do a
press release to do a press release meet
come on it's so easy in the media to do
a press release and oh by the way we're
Altria so we're gonna buy five hundred
million dollars worth of advertising
over the next five years
would you please run our story or you
know you might want to look at this come
on it's tobacco so do you think that
they make a deal before they accept the
press release to do advertising or do
they wait a little bit you know it's the
only I have to say anything it's just
the yeah it's implied why do you not
hear why do you not hear the discussion
about overmedication of children on
television does it look at the number
one advertiser right you if you start
talking it's just not discussed you
can't because it is a controversial
subject and it would be a good subject
not has launched a lot of people paying
attention to it it's not like it would
get a lot of ratings if you have a lot
of stories about overmedication of
children people like what what is going
on it would be something people be
interested in yeah and yet they don't do
it because the adverts right I mean
that's Lou look at your advertise I have
to turn off the sound these days because
I'm sure that I'm being blanketed with
so many ads that eventually I'm going to
get propecia eventually I'm going to get
high blood pressure I mean my dicks not
gonna work
because that's what your telling you
every every commercial block now
everyone its pharmaceutical until you
know like cable news especially because
an older demographic but even if you
watch what is it
what do they have a where they have two
and a half men running all TV land to a
Half Men and what's the other one
Doug and Carrie come on Kevin James is a
to enough men no no the Doug and Carrie
where is that you okay in Queens take a
quiz yeah but I don't watch uh i sitcoms
I can watch that that's funny show I can
just watch it over and over I'm good
dude but then very funny every
commercial break
boom drugs yeah what is it which
documentary was it there that had a
description about the United States
saying that we are one of two countries
in the world that allows advertisers yes
foster alia is the other I think it's
New Zealand okay let's see the
Australian sorry either one because
that's like a real [ __ ] yeah call out
the wrong one of those things pretty
sure it's New Zealand but that for
whatever reason that everybody else is
like what are you crazy and once we got
it in there it's like once something
becomes something that everybody does we
are crazy it's really difficult it's
crazy that we do that let me get you a
blunt but this coffee by the way is
phenomenal you are legit man who do this
yeah that's pretty good though what is
this Swede
my mother would roll over in a you know
grave she saw well she's dead oh but she
didn't like it but she would just be
like I don't know your mom Joe I mean
it's like you know my mom smokes pot
yeah my mom was not a pot smoker I grew
up with the Emily Post etiquette you
know I still if a woman comes in I'll
stand up at the table oh good for you
well the Texas that's I love that one
that one of things that I really love
about Austin in particular this is kind
of a hybrid of hippies and Texas people
yeah you know that's how I feel yeah and
I like that I'd like yeah I like having
guns I like the whole idea of you know
protecting my family yeah and being able
to take out an evil government yeah I
like that
whoa well that's what it's for right the
Second Amendment is to protect the First
Amendment that's that's my view and and
we got a culture is it you go we have a
gun culture in Texas so and also people
are really nice in the car to each other
yeah it's like go ahead man after you
it's fine no one really there's no real
road rage well there's that expression
right a well-armed society is a polite
society
mm-hm now I'm not saying that that's my
rainbows and unicorns of the world I'm
not either but it works yeah that's work
it does work there's places where people
are armed that it's a really nice place
to be
it doesn't mean bad things can't happen
there and what does that that's very
interesting
this stuff yeah yeah I've never done a
blunt oh it's good right Charlie Murphy
got me anything so that's a pre premade
blunt mhm yeah Charlie would actually
make them so how much tobacco is in
there versus it's the leaf on the
outside is it rolled on the thighs of
virgins I don't believe so I like
building
I don't know Bill Hicks is bit I do know
that some sicko he bizarre supposed to
be rolled on the thighs of virgins
well it's marketing it's out a bit about
good marketing rolled with Claudia
Schiffer's [ __ ] lips I think that's
what I know skinny Lincoln hot yes
definitely skinny yeah but um it's
wasn't she married to David Copperfield
but she's still with him or was with him
for a long time I don't know I try not
to pay attention to who's [ __ ] who it
seems like it was a while ago and kind
of celebrity this at that it's going
down I don't know [ __ ] she still looks
hot though saw a picture of her mm-hmm
some of them gals can't keep it together
good skin yeah
good skin drinks a lot of water good
habits I guess mm-hmm I'm so back to the
vape pen thing yeah so someone needs to
make a documentary that that is a crazy
little sneaky move or at least a YouTube
video multi-billion dollar scam
propagated again
multiple states in the United States and
free choice of consumers all to protect
an industry that essentially we're
trying to get away with with vaping yeah
because I've been an addicted smoker all
my life smoke cigarettes from at least
15 probably earlier then luckily got
into weed and smoke you know been
smoking all my life pretty much but I
still would you know would roll it with
tobacco which does give you an extra
delivery mechanism and extra kind of
kind of kick yeah but then I would just
from time to time just smoke one a
cigarette and I really it was first of
all it's chemicals and all kinds of
[ __ ] is in there stinks to stinks up
the house yeah I want to live longer you
know so this is this great no I'm sure
it isn't you look very good for a person
who smoked a long time about 55 you look
great for 55 you really do you look a
lot younger than I think if if you if
you took me and compressed me down I'd
look like you really long muscles like
we push it all down yeah it would be
better yeah but your health yours like
you look like a healthy person so I do
the dancing and I go to ride indoor
cycling oh can you spin that's excellent
oh my god and bits is more like a dance
orient you wanna use it and it's just
[ __ ] loud music and it's all in rhythm
and you've kind of got a group vibe
going on and and cardio of course is
fantastic they also do weights you know
cool three pound weights there's
something really cool about doing stuff
with a group of people you know more any
kind of difficult thing yeah everybody's
pushing everybody come on let's go it's
fun and so a lot of spin classes are
really that really competitive like mad
about you see the peloton ads like but
that's not what this is this is you do
you're standing you're sitting you're
tapping back you're doing crunch crunch
is you're doing push-ups all to the
beats of the faster the beat of course
the faster you're doing it so it's it's
like dancing but then on a bike when I
like being yelled at in you know the
dark room boot camp vibe so I don't have
my hearing aids in it or my glasses on
so I'm kind of like yeah you're blurry
right now but I can't see
so I can't see the hottie instructor of
there doesn't make any difference but
something about the vibe so I get into
it yeah tell me about the hearing aids
because you took him out when you got in
Oh put the headphones on and this this
is from listening to music too loud no
that what you'd think you'd think they'd
think no I have a genetic problem that I
didn't know about until three years ago
and so it's not and I you know went to
an audiology here's what happened I
started noticing Tina and I had been
together for a couple of years I started
noticing I was saying excuse me what I
just I wouldn't hear stuff or she would
say something that I couldn't remember
hearing and and I brought it up to her
and I said you know see what do you
think I asked you to repeat something a
lot just uh doesn't really bother me and
then says but the TV is very loud so
really the TV is very loud said oh I
don't even realize that so I went to an
audiologist and lo and behold my
grandmother on my dad's side was
completely deaf almost from her teens so
I have some of this but it's been okay
only as you get older everything the
levels you know to see like here's
here's a level where you can hear
everything and I was already kind of
there so now it's just due to age
because everything goes down a bit and
so I'm missing 1 K and 1 kilohertz
something missing different different
tones and so I went to an audiologist
and said well it's very mild but yeah
this can make you repeat stuff and it
will get worse over time and what
actually happens to a lot of men in
particulars they they become very
isolated from the world they don't even
realize that they have a hearing problem
and now the difference between having
them in and taking them out is massive
just you know I can hear how much less
it is another clue was that I have a for
my all my podcast radio work I've no
headphone but I put an extra amplifier
on you can see you could still hear it
today sometimes I'm talking and it'll
leak just a little bit because they have
it so loud now that's not I'm gonna
damage my ears but the problem with
anything you put in your ears you don't
you can't hear the sounds anymore
I like that our processing our EQ it's
very important to me so I can hear that
without the hearing aids but not with
the hearing aids wow that's interesting
so the hearing aids give you a different
kind of sound well so today's hearing
aid is not your your Grandpa's you know
geriatric brown goopy looking piece of
[ __ ] that makes you look like a just a
total [ __ ] like how dare you you did
the face I did the face
hey it's disability here I get a victim
card okay you get a probably a plate
boundaries [ __ ] boundaries okay so
these are the wide X evoke these have 35
channels of compressor limiter multiple
settings
it's an in-ear so it goes right into my
ear I still have a little bleed through
from the outside world but because of
usually an audiologist sticks this thing
in your ears and makes you do all the
tests and then they'll sit there and
they'll sit across from you and they're
gonna program it so that you can then
hear a normal sound which is very it's a
very it used to be a trained
professionals very hard to fix someone
who has never heard what is proper okay
now I'm a little different and I'm also
weighing the sound and so it's a whole
rack at these things at three and a half
thousand dollars it's it's a huge racket
and the way they do it is the
manufacturer you can't buy from the
directly or from retail you can only buy
it through an audiologist so they're
already getting half the money from the
other 1,500 release and you have to have
a you know appointment so it's all this
money that goes on top and then you come
back after a couple months and they
tweak it you come back again so I said
look see Who I am
I've told you what I do give me the
[ __ ] software she said oh no no I was
going to give it to you I just wanted to
do one session with you said you have to
have this so I have may have
pre-programmed like six different
programs so I can do one just for music
I can do one for television one for
social situations and I have one that
and I so I did it all myself all these
50 35 different channels of compressor
limiter
so when I'm walking around what I hear
on my ears is like a radio show like the
sound like when I'm talking right now I
hear my own voice
and it all resonates because I've jacked
all that up so I've made my own sound
reality of sound but I also have one I
can set it to a setting in the mall I
can hear a conversation from 50 feet
away whoa my my special my eavesdropping
setting now the only thing that doesn't
work is you can't have headphones
because that that doesn't work having
the hearing aids in with the headphones
with the sound yeah because you're
blasting into the microphone it really
doesn't work that's crazy though that
you could hear people having a
conversation 50 feet away can you focus
in on people well by turning my head
yeah my tournament yes I mean there's a
lot you can you can focus you can have
it automatic so the problem is the way
I've set it up you can drop a pen there
if I don't see it I might hear it over
there yeah now that's always going to be
a problem they have they have an
algorithm that will try to guess where
the sound is from and tell your ears
that so basically I'm not the guy you
want in the battlefield
Wow
but just for yeah so it just doesn't
work with headphones that's why I take
them out it's amazing though they sound
incredibly potent like oh yeah you
remember I mean you know what real sound
sounds yes yes everything sound real to
you or yes there well what you
automatically do because I was able to
do it from having a common have
different settings for different
situations so if I'm at home it's
relatively quiet or we have some music
on or you know TV or whatever now I have
Tina frequency which is you know kind of
like 1 kilohertz and and that's where I
hear her better and so that's jacked up
a little bit but then if I hear you talk
I can hear it'll be a little I can hear
it's not exactly you it's a little too
tinny maybe so but that's just me I mean
that's not everyone's experience of
course but to me it's the disability has
become an incredible joy because I have
like virtual reality on my head although
I was just saying that you could
probably [ __ ] with someone's voice like
a snapchat filter well you know they can
sound l'heure
it's really advanced I mean you can
connect to an iPhone so you can you can
stream wirelessly you can do like if
you're driving with directions with the
maps you can just be talking and in your
ear all sounds like it the like turn
right no one else hears it there's no
wire there's no nothing I got you know
you wouldn't even know I had them in
unless you look yeah we're becoming
cyborgs oh yeah that's all though I'm
against it that is a part of the the the
road to transhumanism right but how can
you say you're against it where you're
enjoying this thing this to me is more
it's not a replacement it's an
enhancement yeah you know and that's how
they're gonna get us gets his legs
removed for artificial carbon-fiber legs
that you could feel but they can rub a
little hex t miles and now when the
first guy gets his legs removed yeah in
favor of new legs that's when we're
gonna go holy [ __ ]
whenever I tell my radio buddies about
my hearing aids they're always like oh
that's [ __ ] cool it's like I want
that don't get it me wrong I'm just
looking at the bleak landscape ahead of
us by the way beware I just want to say
something because there's a lot of
they're not called hearing aids are
called hearing amplifiers they have some
fuzzy legal language that are coming on
the market you know that you put all the
way in year the rechargeables got a
whole bunch of them they're much much
cheaper from an audio standpoint I've
done it for 40 years that's not the way
you want to go if you seriously want to
know how to if you want to hear properly
again so see an audiologist is what I'm
saying and there's lots of different you
know it doesn't it's not all 3.5
thousand dollars it's more expensive but
don't I just recommend it that's it self
testing is not a good idea one of the
best pool players in the world is a guy
named Shane Van Bonin and Shane is deaf
he was born deaf and when he plays he
shuts his hearing aids off and just it's
a world of silence and he's just playing
in complete total silence and when he
does that when he shuts his his hearing
it off he feels like he's got super
concentration like it doesn't matter
what else is going on always doing is
just focusing on the balls and there's
no that that sense doesn't exist so he
can he's
focused on other things I noticed that
sometimes when I walk with
noise-canceling headset same thing it'll
do similar I'll smell things more well
that's kind of well known yeah different
parts of your body compensate for you
have something more tuned in more tuned
like let's pay attention here
the ears are off line amount line can be
running behind you and you listen in the
[ __ ] exactly is considered and that's
it yeah but that's all think about it if
you can't hear the mountain lion
frequencies anymore and today's mountain
lion is you know car engines all kinds
of stores you can't hear it it's
dangerous and it's and you don't know it
you just slip into it I had no idea
until you know mm-hmm we have a new
relationship you know so we've been
living together for a couple years and
luckily it you know we're completely
open and honest like hey if this is
[ __ ] up yeah so cool that that exists
though I mean that's an elegant solution
and for someone like you it's actually
gives you a chance to tinker with [ __ ]
and I'm sure I'm sure you really enjoy
that aspect of it yeah it's a small
thing but if you talk about the apps on
your phone you're so excited about that
that whole band like okay do you use
UNIX or Linux you oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah
so think pad you think bad guy no I'm
not I'm not that deep I actually love
the I'm deep I'm not that deep and I
used to be a Mac guy and then Mac
started [ __ ] up their USB interfaces
and I got tired of it and then I went to
Windows a lot of the top DJ's you know
like the Danger Mouse and these guys are
all going windows and the audio or my
own check it out and you know some good
device is available and so I made this
transition and then I was kind of on
Windows and like holy [ __ ] Microsoft is
spying on everything Windows 10 there's
like a hundred different telemetry
pieces of [ __ ] going out every single
day they're just like Apple by the way
they're they're advertising too you're
like oh use word over here and try out
this it's just I can't stand it I can't
stand that that you know I have to have
an account to use Microsoft Word right I
don't want it it's just it's no one
else's business and so I bought the
surface go which is ten inch screen it's
a tablet but has a
on keyboard and I just load Lubuntu
which is a lightweight version of Ubuntu
and and I use that as Linux yeah yeah
yeah it's Linux tell those people out
there that don't know [ __ ] the only
problem
well the only problem is that there
really is no good multitrack audio
solution for Linux it just please don't
email me I've been following this [ __ ]
for decades it's not there you don't
know what you're talking about
you know it's an issue with companies
not want to do drivers and there being
no platform but that's too bad so I
still produce our show on Windows but
the rest of my life is is all Linux and
my flip phone is that your desktop there
it's just a little bunch I just picked
up it's beautiful it's the idea I mean
what do you use for a word processor if
you don't use word Libre Office Libre
before I can write we've tried to move
to Linux so many times you know I feel
like hey man I'm gonna 10 years ago I
might install Linux okay the DRI
couldn't get the screen to work you know
whatever [ __ ] was he because I'm not
you know it's we're just hacking around
and then like in the last year I said
I'm gonna try it again and it's stuck
you know like it work is good enough and
now we like yes our official distro is
Linux Mint 19 that's the one you all
want to have and by the way you know
have your kid learn how to install it on
some old computer it'll teach the kid
something and so Libre offers just been
this running joke cuz Libre means free
and you know I like this lovey-dovey
because it is it's free as in free opens
open source software yeah I think I know
some people get attached that Microsoft
it in terms of like office suite know
different things but well I just use
word that's really well and you can save
in Word format you know it doesn't make
any difference and I think it's really
good you know as far as like a word
processing for if that's all I think
about like how well does it do it for me
it's information management and email i
i i use clause mail and you can really
customize it survive filters and and
like cording commands so i can by by
doing this
then it'll send back a message like hey
man thanks for this and then it'll
forward a copy to the back office and
save it unread in the show folder you
know like that kind of stuff if you want
to get balls deep into the world of
computer technology it's a long river
there's a lot but up to now I've been
using my first computer was the sinclair
zx80 Sinclair's and I build my own modem
which was I think basically like I don't
know five baud I guess to commune with
an acoustic modem you know so we
basically ripped open a phone put the
two pieces in boxes and then put another
hand side on top here Jamie's got it
that's it yeah that's it the sinclair
zx80 judy you did that at five baud I
remember when I switched from 14 for
waiting before that and then my dad
always had computers around the house
and I was on line on a very early in
that's amazing look at that thing so I
was hacking with that stuff Wow and then
you know the trash 82 you know TRS 100
which was a kind of a laptop on
batteries vic-20 commodore 64 so when
this first started happening and you
started getting going on Usenet you know
and you started getting a taste of the
Internet like my experience was a AOL I
gather I picked up an Apple home
computer from one of them office stores
whatever the chain was I don't think
they're around anymore it was like so it
was actually oh compusa course so
computer superstore yeah my friend Robby
used to actually make computers or sell
computers for a living so who's telling
me what to get and I got home and I
somehow another connected to AOL and
then I remember going to the first thing
I did was go and try to find UFO FILES
that's always trying to find like what
are the government's files on UFOs I
want to read whatever the [ __ ] you can
read I want you know I want to know what
they know I was downloading all this
[ __ ] from these like crude AOL boards
and like these online searches we could
online search things you just Archie
yeah you would get all the paperwork
number Archie the search engine Archie
Archie and then you had Veronica they
would search the
types of servers remember gopher do you
ever get into gopher gopher I don't
remember either that was pretty so check
this out Jamie does Jamie so gopher was
basically the world wide web only there
was no web and so you could log on to a
terminal and you could use a menu system
so basically with the arrow keys but it
might you go to the right you might be
connecting to a different computer at a
different University ie a different
server and then you could have a so it
was basically all these information
documents linking to each other and I
started one I registered mtv.com which
was Wow and I went to him and said hey I
want to do this thing on the Internet
we're a lot of our audiences and I want
to register mtv.com yeah that's cool
don't worry about it we have the AOL
keyword so you go ahead and do your
little internet thing there son do
whatever you want so I had this girl and
I'm promoting it on air you know go to
MTV comm for my gopher server yeah that
it was wild you could do [ __ ] then at
MTV yeah and in fact at first I got an
email from the University of Michigan or
that the Gophers is that their symbol
Minnesota oh my god
thank you and they said dude you're
using this commercially you have to pay
us five thousand dollars for a license
I'm like just for the server software
which is open you know free but they do
something in the license head I'm doing
this just in my own they don't give a
[ __ ] I'm just doing this I don't have
$5,000 really didn't I don't $5,000 said
if you send me a t-shirt I'll wear it on
MTV and they said okay and I guess my
document you can see that there's a
video on YouTube with me with the Gopher
t-shirt on MTV and they're like oh man
so anyway then that's cool on them too
so I got this set up and I got an email
from this guy in Champaign Urbana
Illinois and it's like hey Adam see what
you're doing with mtv.com look I got
this thing that I've created this mosaic
browser and can you install the server
httpd 1.4 or whatever and that was Marc
Andreessen the guy who went on to create
Netscape Wow and you know I was now on
one of the biggest VC in
in Silicon Valley and when I saw that oh
[ __ ] this is like graphic like a webpage
when we used to images would take a long
time to load this would be black and
white progressively loading them become
color like like a porn picture took an
hour to download you yeah I remember the
first time a friend sent me a porn video
he's like look at this I was like what
you can send a video what was it you
remember what it was a girl giving a guy
a [ __ ]
and it only lasted like 15 so of course
and that was you know and it took you
two hours of down forever remember I'm
using it you would download from 15
different things and you get like all
these different files and you had a
program that put it back together
[ __ ] what is this
they are the Gopher t-shirt oh there you
are those days give me to everybody
do those days feel like like a different
human being when you look back at that
like that's a long-ass time ago and
because of the time yes I'm sure MTV was
like back then and just life back then
it means well don't you have that
yourself just with age yeah I mean so of
course but yeah is it's all still a part
of me that MTV period is so definitively
closed because it's just not it that
will never come back yeah I mean it was
a magical time it was fun and to this
day it can be in the oddest places it's
usually a guy in in a suit and tie
oh that I have yeah I can catch things
like people drop a a bottle I catch it
on the way down that's my superpower you
get arrested you get a superpower
that's my catching silver it's super
reflexes are good usually a guy in a
suit and tie and all of sudden it's like
and the tie comes off and like Metallica
t-shirt I love that and we share that
and you know that's a shared experience
that that only
only our generation has yeah and then
you know once once be et started getting
the you know Anton TV had to buy B et
because they were you know getting world
premieres from Michael Jackson oh so
that was the whole thing there and you
know it just got commoditized they were
so smart to go on they did the smarter
the people who are running at the time
were very smart to go with long-form
programming they saw it with the remote
control and of course they already had
seen a little bit of it with what's the
first reality show they had forget
what's called the real world real world
yeah so they you know because the MTV
ratings during the day were 0.5
basically and I was always proud that I
would sometimes break one but I had
interesting shows that you know people
like to watch like dial MTV that was the
precursor to Total Request Live Carson
Daly show so I did that and you know
that was just the top ten of the day but
people had the idea that they were
making a difference in the in the chart
which they weren't because it was number
one can you guess what was number one
requested every single day what New Kids
on the Block they it was the biggest
problem in MTV the other sometimes they
just did they didn't make it on Jeep or
we're not playing anything under number
five today Oh New Kids on the Block er
6g which it was it was kind of [ __ ]
kind of [ __ ] yeah didn't that come
up recently discharged her with like
Twitter I couldn't Twitter trending top
did so hard on Twitter they had to stop
him from being number one what they
would be number one better like Taylor
Swift or Beyonce someone would be oh
yeah well if anyone has any idea that
this is fair these these rankings and
[ __ ] that it's it's all weird
everybody's competing hey Joe this is
really nice yeah they're having a really
good time - I'm really happy here really
I always want to be part of kind of the
pirate crew out here and now I feel like
I've kind of connected I swear to God we
didn't try to be a pirate crew that's
what's the weirdest thing about the
whole thing there was no thought about
it at all I just kept doing it there was
never a plan I mean I mean as far as the
plans making this building that
kind of a plane right which is
incredible and it's just beautiful to
see I love you got a clubhouse you got
it's a fun club that like an
honest-to-god grown up dude clubhouse
yeah it feels good in this place it's
got good memories it's got a good feel
to it mm-hmm but but through your show
you know you've introduced and you know
I would say mainly the comedian's it's
been the best just and thank God for
Netflix and all this stuff that's
happening it's just this is kind of
nucleus of it all yeah and and and it's
it's a lot it's interesting to be able
to see and watch and this I think
comedians change the world when when
they're good at it and when they care
and I'm seeing more and more of it and I
like it you know maybe time for a little
bit of pushback here and there yeah it's
I think what it is is we have a place
where comedians can go and give you like
from them to you
for the first time and it's never really
like the most she ever had was like a
moment if you're a talk-show host where
you could address the camera I just
remember there's a really powerful
moment when what's-his-name the English
guy that just Craig Craig Daniels Craig
Craig first thank you sorry is that
English Suzy is the Irish Scottish sorry
Craig I like him a lot but he had this
moment where he's talking about Britney
Spears mm-hmm we really looked at the
camera and he said it was about her
being crazy like when she shaved her
head like what are you doing what are we
doing like why I found this girl this
poor girls losing their mind yeah I
found her alone hounding her leave her
alone yeah and that really is what it is
is like once someone like that becomes a
topic mm-hmm and it's a subject that
they can get clicks on and views and and
ratings
they'll just hound that poor girl what
do you got Bill Cosby in jail yeah
that's right mm-hmm yeah that's right
Hannibal yeah it's some talk about
Peyton cancel I know the next level
canceled yeah and he deserve that
deserved every minute of it
it's very strange right he's the
strangest of all of them
when I was a kid we would listen to his
album where he he talked about God
talking to Noah the conversation God
know hilarious hilarious work it was
great great comedy
it's hard to imagine that the whole time
he was doing that spooky it's hard to
imagine how I'm going to drive back to
the airport
in a straight line like a wizard do you
have no problem hang out here for a
while - good good
you could go work out music is hurt but
how about that sauna though I like that
oh you didn't sell enough that not it's
a rave man yeah do you sauna at all
no I love it I have I just have a play
in Amsterdam I had a place with a sauna
in the house that was nice it's so
undeniably good for you if you do it all
the time but then I'd be smoking weed in
the sauna don't do that no I was right
you could smoke weed and then get in
there mmm that's not a problem that's
probably good hey I like it a lot it's
good experience is he done the flow tank
I did that once I did not like that at
all I lost your phobic no no I just was
I couldn't I couldn't get into any kind
of zone or vibe I just kept like I'm
laying here in lukewarm water like I'm
not hearing anything I was like no mi
thing am i liking this it's getting a
little cold Ordo it's getting warm right
so I couldn't I couldn't well that is a
real issue if it's not temperature
control correctly and you feel cold
it'll [ __ ] up your experience you really
want it in that perfect sweet zone but
when you can get there it's really all
about whether or not you know how to
concentrate on breathing if you can just
concentrate on breathing done breath
work yeah it was very interesting it's
not a difficult formula that I employ
but I'll tell you guys if you listen if
you also float when I get in there I
touch the sides to Center myself so that
I don't bounce against anything and
distract myself because I'm floating you
know and you drift into the wall
sometimes so I wait until the ripples
die down because when you climb in
there's gonna be like a little bit of
ripple edge right and then when you lay
down once the water gets still then I
let my hands go and then I just think
about breathing and I thought I'm not a
wizard at this right it goes in and out
I think about I forgot to call that guy
I gotta send that email oh I got a I got
a book that I got to put that on my
calendar I keep
and then if I just stay vigilant and
make sure okay okay get back on the road
and the bat the road is thinking only of
the breathing only of the in and out and
in and out I just like visualized air
coming in and out of my lungs and just
that alone while lying in the tank would
put me in a trance it takes a while but
I can do it quicker because I've done it
for years because the tanks a normal
thing I get in I'm like hob the most I
always think is I should do this more
often
that's what I usually think but I can
get into trance by just thinking about
the breathing yeah Tina and I did a
breath work clinic I forget what it was
called but you do it was like this
tribal beat and you had to continue to
breathe to the beat and wait and you
have one person will be watching you and
then you team up but we didn't team up
together but it's just like that and
then this beat is going and then you do
the breath work and then all sudden you
go into a trance it's different for
everybody and I could fly
and that was my just like 30 minutes I'm
just flying and yet right after you had
to draw what you were doing I mean it's
one of these well yeah I'm a little I'm
a little hippie - I like this stuff it's
good so you draw it and then I just
Joyce I was flying I was like but I like
this man kind of yeah I got man but but
I could just because I I'm a pilot so I
knew how sure yeah I was like oh [ __ ]
this is all I need and you know the
people had different experience with one
woman who I was partnered with her turn
and she just and they told me that she
could get a little funky and she just
kind of got out of it and picked up a
plastic bat next to her which I had seen
she starts hammering the pillows like
really blah blah blah oh my god mm-hmm
and it's just you know but fantastic you
come out of it you're like wow I mean
that was just such a great experience
I bet that [ __ ] does that Starbucks - I
bet she's just wild just look pretty
stupid she does the yoga class starts
punching the walls through this pose
oh maybe not maybe so but no thanks but
holotropic breathing I think they call
that that's probably what it was yeah I
mean I know that is one of them I don't
know maybe there's other methods that
they do it but the people that do it say
it gets your high as [ __ ] see if we were
live than Tina would text me now just
like she knows all that yeah I think our
Brees done that [ __ ] I think it's
holotropic breathing right is that the
only psychedelic breathe is there's a
for sure method that people you could do
so much with your breathing yeah do all
kinds of crazy things I mean have you
ever done you seen those yoga dudes you
can suck their stomach in and do that
yeah is the thing where there's
autonomic kills in the side I don't find
it particularly attractive it's it's
very impressive yeah I don't know like
I've never really understood it like
what do you do I didn't know it was an
exercise I just thought it was showing
off I don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing because even though it's it's
impressive I've never attempted it it's
one of those things where looking like
oh yeah look at that like that it's
impressive but but to someone who can
actually do the thing is like I don't
know what they're doing I have no idea
but there was this famous Jiu Jitsu guy
named Hicks and Gracie and he was famous
for it he was one of the first guys to
incorporate yoga into martial arts like
really seriously and it's the greatest
Gracie of all time right and he would
lay there there's this there's this
video for this movie choke where he's
sitting there in a lotus position he's
doing this crazy [ __ ] with his stomach I
can't believe it's real watch this look
at this watch this
this is Hickson why do this like this
intense breathing but then see he would
move his stomach oh this from the movie
choke but watch what he could do with
his stomach oh yeah yeah yeah look yeah
look at this crazy [ __ ] where I could
pull it to the left into the right
he has like ultimate control over his
breath and that strength and control
over his breath from all these breathing
exercises that he did it was a big part
of like how he could fight and how he
could how was jiu-jitsu was so strong he
had incredible breath control
incredible body when you say why his
jiu-jitsu was so strong what does that
mean exactly
he was what the mole
dominant of the most dominant families
fighting seals in jiu-jitsu okay
he's alleged like a legit like there's
there's very few Universal legends I
should come during one of your like
fighter talk things I would learn a lot
yeah it's interesting this guy's one of
the most interesting he's one of the
most interesting because his family in
Brazil was famous for creating this form
of jiu-jitsu Brazilian jiu-jitsu that
went on to win the Ultimate Fighting
Championship and really revolutionized
martial arts right but he was the
champion of the family and not just by a
small margin by a large universally
agreed-upon margin where all of them
would go Hickson's the king like no
one's even close
everyone says that he would go and he
would get some of the best black belts
in the world like a hundred of them in a
room and he would just one after the tap
amount one after the other
fighting is no he's an older man now and
you know he's teaches and he I know he
still trains and he's involved in these
big seminars because his opinion is very
very respected because it was an intense
level Jiu Jitsu that he was able to
achieve but he literally at peaked he
hit past everyone he figured something
out to get way above everyone hmm and I
think that had a lot to do with it I
think the yoga and the mindset or
meditation his mind was strong and then
because of the yoga his body was really
flexible and really like well
conditioning can contort and these
amazing ways to achieve submissions and
then also his jiu-jitsu was so sharp
like his family created it and
everything was polished everyone knew
everything that the correct defense the
correct offense where you never make
mistakes can't be in this position
always be here abandon that and go to
this you have planned BCD and you keep
going with through mass just running
like running these trains of techniques
on people it's special to watch anyone
else like him there's a bunch of guys
now there's a bunch of [ __ ] assassins
now but in his day he was just there's
no one person that stands out above like
everyone this is kid Gordon Ryan who's
this really elite submission artist who
taps everybody in competition and he's
trained what I'm sorry what submission
artist mean well there's Jiu Jitsu with
Aggie
right with which is just you know
jujitsu rules they vary depending upon
the organization but you where the key
and you can use the key you can choke
people gears is your address your ass
the white the white kimono or the blue
one people have bolted a guy from the
commercial says no this is my business
key yeah yeah right but even a jacket
you know like you're using clothes right
the idea is like if you got into the
fight was like judo
yes exactly either that actually comes
from part of Judo called knee Wazza
which the ground I did a little judo's
okay very very little
jujitsu came out of judo judo is the
original and Japanese Jiu Jitsu and then
it became Brazilian Jiu Jitsu when the
Brazilians legitimate changed it and
altered it and then there's submission
grappling submission grappling there's
no key so most of the time guys we're
like rash guards like skin-tight like
surfer rash guards those kind of okay or
you know or skin tight short can't
really I can't really hold on to it
exactly their ideas you can you can't
grab close it's just about it's like
wrestling mm-hmm but it's wrestling with
chokes and armbars and okay in that
world there's a guy named Gordon Ryan
has a real prodigy and his his trainer
is considered to be one of the all-time
great trainers his name is John Danaher
and they come from hens Oh Gracie's
Academy in New York City which is one of
the greatest to Jitsu schools like
universally recognized ever and is this
giant gym in Manhattan it is it just so
many killers have come out of this one
place so that kid is probably the top of
the food chain today out of everybody
but even his dominance is probably
slightly different from Hickson's
because Hickson was there was no losses
there was no draws it was like it was
just dominating people cuz everyone got
dominated and everybody came out of it
going what the [ __ ]
he just ran through everybody what what
how did it end for him what was his last
pixon yeah a big exit no well you had a
giant fight against this very dangerous
guy he began in 2000 and that was an MMA
fight and he beat his ass and that's a
nice exit that's nice he won out on top
never nobody ever beat him in a mixed
martial arts fight really didn't fight a
lot of the there was a lot of
opportunities for different people that
he could have fought but he just didn't
want to didn't feel like it he's just a
free spirit
but my point I don't want the [ __ ] 1
point well here's it question a stomach
thing
deuce what it was that was anything
that's where it was do you think it's a
gene or is it the environment that I
have absolutely no interest in fighting
of any kind I don't watch it I'm not
I saw the Thrilla in Manilla my dad got
me up in the middle of the night you're
living overseas to see it and I thought
I appreciated that as a as a world event
yeah it's just never I've what is it I'm
some people I like I just don't I don't
understand it I don't like it I think
it's cool you don't understand it
understand it's probably there's nothing
in me that says oh yeah I want see like
I beat the other guy's ass yeah that's
that should be perfect you know in a
perfect world everybody should be like
that
okay well legitimately I respect it I
like where you're coming from
never I'm fascinating I'm very
interested as I said I did a little judo
that was mainly because I was getting
picked on at school my dad said here
yeah going to judo and so I learned how
to you know fall and how to we dive over
like five kids and then roll and get up
again after that got kind of a little I
didn't like it you know like just I
don't know I didn't like and they went
fencing I was actually very good at
fencing
I liked that a lot martial arts for
competition is a it's a strange pursuit
and professionally for competition it's
an even stranger pursuit like originally
the martial artist gets into martial
arts because they want to better
themselves they want to be better at
fighting they want to have confidence
they want to be able to be competitive
but just like you want guns to be able
to defend yourself there's a lot of
people that want to learn how to
physically defend them against man right
right right
I've always said this like if people say
like why do you do it why do you work
out and what it means first health and
sanity first oh but a second very
important I want to be the one who
decides if we're in an altercation and
you decide you're some bully and you run
up on me and you think you're just gonna
hit me I want to be the one who decides
who goes to the hospital not you I don't
want you think I were seeing I grew up
so sheltered I never was really ever
threatened
anyway every day all around the world it
happens to somebody and if you're lucky
you live your whole life by going into
the right places
and never get punched and never never
gets just stole on where somebody just
comes up to you and just starts smacking
you around
now you can't defend yourself because it
[ __ ] happens yeah people do it to
people people are awful yeah you know
and it's most people are not the vast
majority or not but you know you do that
[ __ ] the wrong guy like and you don't
you didn't know better and you did that
too bas Rutten who's a former UFC
heavyweight champion is one of the
nicest guys ever you might get confused
and think like god you don't know maybe
who he is maybe you think you're gonna
bully him maybe think you're gonna [ __ ]
with them make them uncomfortable and
next thing you know you wake up in the
hospital I think I'm just reflecting
here I have a childhood memory would
make which may be where this started for
me I remember and I went I entered Dutch
school in fifth grade
speaking almost know Dutch it was kind
of a [ __ ] up situation though um so
but say around sixth grade and I was
learning a little bit on the street and
around but I definitely was not not
really 100% fluent and I can't remember
what it was is in the it was in the gym
in the locker room and some kids
something said something and he was much
smaller than I was and I said something
like well I can take care of you little
man and it probably I should have said
it in the first place but within like a
nanosecond Wow
and I'm like you know he's put me down
you know hit me in the on the nose and
yeah and I'm like oh [ __ ] me I and that
meant I think that was the moment where
I'm like I should definitely be careful
what I say into who I say it and I
should watch my mouth but maybe that
excuse me from right that from that
moment all for sure that's yeah for sure
that was yeah so I was like how many 12
something like that oh man for sure that
that's gonna leave a stain
yeah consciousness oh thank you for
bringing this up yeah this is like
therapy right this is great right I mean
I think everybody needs to know why
things bother them why things like
conflict bother them does this has I
don't know as I'm you're 50 52
yeah so almost we're same age basically
do you have more of those moments now
that you think oh [ __ ] that's that's
what happened then and that's why I'm
having those which means we're just
you're doing something and you think
back to a moment like I just had here
hey that happened maybe that does
influence me now today how I respond
situation yeah I'm having more of those
and my always having that too that's
smart I like it a lot yeah it's very
interesting I think oh god if I only
known this mm-hmm 20 years ago
you're the origin of your behavior is an
interesting thing the origin of your
idea yeah and where you are now you know
it's a you know we're just the way we
choose to behave about things it's very
strange but anybody doing something like
that to you when you're that age I must
have been an insanely traumatic
experience you wouldn't want to watch I
didn't even tell my parents about it I
didn't tell my parents about it yeah I
was so ashamed yeah yeah it's hard no
the the solution to that as strange as
it sounds is everybody know how to fight
right getting their way less fights if
it sounds great it's right on I think
there's you know it's taught I think it
should be taught just for peace whereas
we seem to be going kind of the opposite
direction with the with a general mmm
cultural education of young men at least
yes in the United States I don't know if
it's the same everywhere I think it may
be kind of propagating out there some of
the nicest people I know are martial
arts people so of course because they
have their ego in a good place in their
sin to the general population
they've been humbled in training
everybody gets humbled in training it's
so good for you it really is and it
leaves you calm like you get exercise in
and you get some sort of a weird therapy
to from when you're a man and just
knowing that you aren't you you know
aren't helpless I've seen people that
are helpless it's very sad
I think it comes from anything you learn
like learning how to fly yeah you
literally helpless if you're doing it
wrong and an instructor a good
instructor will you know help you get
into situations that you have to get out
of
and that same feeling arrives I think
that that's a part of just the learning
process yeah I should probably try it
you'd love it yeah what should I try
what would the well listen at Tina's
laughing right off like oh yeah oh yeah
after this and I'll find a okay spot we
could go and learn and just you would
get a kick out of just the learning just
like you get a kick out of learning the
dancing yeah exactly specially like if
you take something like more tie more
types of fun I saw I was I did a
documentary in Thailand did you really
how is really quite Slive oh yeah yeah I
love the rhythm of the music you know
it's all cute clued in to how they do
their [ __ ] yeah I went up to the Burmese
border the Golden Triangle stayed with
the hilltribe whoa I've done a lot of
crazy stuff documentaries what is that
how come watch that it's called Veronica
goes and Veronica was the the
organization that I worked for in the
Netherlands the broadcast company is it
available online could someone find
probably bits of it on YouTube Veronica
goes Asia and so it was Thailand I mean
we did a number of things we went into
brothel you know where the girls have
all the numbers and we film there I oh
man I'm going to the longnecks you know
would they have all the rings on and I
was thinking oh this is gonna be great
we're going to see the long next four
and a half hours and the first to get
from Shanghai to Shanghai up in the
north then a four and a five or five
hour bus drive because we said cruise
right so we're 10 people with producers
and everything and it's like it's gotta
be around here and there's like a big
sign almost a neon log next this way I'm
like [ __ ] tourist trap it really is
you know but then we went up to the
hilltribe
I'm sure that they've done it before you
know had crews over but it's only women
cuz all the men are in the opium Hut and
just completely stoned smoking opium the
women run the whole deal and and they
they chew the beetle nut root with uh
with a white paste in it some kind of
cocoa paste and so of course for the
documentary I tried that no and their
mouths are all red your teeth get
completely red from the beetle nut oh my
god and it's like oh [ __ ] and it's like
like an elevator you got a DMT can be a
little bit of an elevator vibes look
guys I'm [ __ ] hammered spit out all
the rest of it and it stayed with me for
a good 45 minutes the sensation like a
bit DMT but very very light version of
it you know yeah so it's a psychedelic I
guess so just just you felt this like
you know it felt kind of clear yeah like
oh this is kind of interesting but
alright I'm pretty high just I don't
know I haven't done a lot of different
drugs so I'm not quite sure but it was
interesting but I don't like the red
teeth it's kind of awkward socially yeah
it's a turn-off
I think the Beatle root non-root night
and cocoa paste or probably coke and
some red stuff well knows what evil not
root what's what's in that jazz
Jamie do we find out you got to see the
women's you got you got to see that you
got to see they're they're red what of
me I think so Veronica goes America Asia
and Caribbean as like an 11 on YouTube
oh yeah France got you we also had to
drink Cobra blood yeah it's kind of sad
because first they piss the Cobra off
and they gonna get the venom and this is
dinner restaurant they get the venom out
of his sacs and then they slit him open
and bleed it into a glass of alcohol and
it's supposed to be very potent it's but
except me that's not you but that's no
but that's this guy's got the teeth of
someone who eats that so he looks very
happy yeah so leave that guy the far
right no anyway do that one who the hell
that's a lady look at her tripping balls
it's happiest [ __ ] anyway but we also
shot a lot of Muay Thai mmm so we went
to like these you know the small like
village fights we just you know kind of
this makeshift ring in the middle of the
jungle and all these people and the
music and just that would be something
that would manage a feudal or magical
you you would enjoy it I think a lot of
twisty and kicky stuff yeah twisting
kicking stuff common like know how to
dance and move your legs around oh I'm
an excellent dancer I bet you are
it's actually my wedding video week so
we got married in May and you know these
days everyone has an iPhone so there's
just video everywhere
and I look at myself dancing I'm like oh
my god
this has to stop this video has to be
illuminated I am actually that guy I'm
so bad
let's at least learn to dance some
proper dances together because then I
can keep my posture up my frame right
and that just became a hey this is kind
of fun
we are doing this with each other yeah
like some people go golfing you know
maybe we'll go dancing
it's a look if you watch like old Fred
Astaire movies real dancing is very
impressive
oh my god yeah here's a strange thing
like okay how did that get associated
with homosexuality Broadway and I love
Broadway musicals right and I think
that's that's where he came but if I
think about the those Fred Astaire type
days like they're only men we're doing
yeah that was a really manly man three
gentlemen who could strut and they
danced around remember where I do this
it's the and of course we always say
Fred Astaire was great but Ginger Rogers
did everything backwards in heels
so right I don't underestimate he's
wearing heels - yeah dance do they think
of top heels yeah her heels are [ __ ]
though but when you're right at least
women back then the days of the crooners
you know Sinatra and the Rat Pack and
hates pieces and when we cos call women
broads and they ass
you know hey some chicks still like that
yeah who's the [ __ ] that made women
wear those [ __ ] shoes you know like
who's the first person that figured out
stilettos well heels well you know why
you know why why they're worn I mean the
initial idea is - because of the angle
and the pressure your calves pump up and
that is deemed as more sexually
attractive in fact I think it's pretty
proven to work that unmeant attraction
to women red lip lipstick is also part
of the blush you have after orgasm blush
on your cheeks all that stuff is sexual
and it's just exploited by a huge
industry yeah for sure it's just where
they talk to checks into it
they heal things especially like imagine
men we're all I love it when the other
ones you love it don't you think it
looks fantastic
I do but imagine if we went the other
way and if men were the ones who somehow
or another by our culture were tricked
into wearing stilettos and the higher
the heel like the the cooler you looked
he looked at the clock we have entire
swathes of men tricked into putting a
noose around their neck every single
morning with all kinds of weird [ __ ] at
least that kind of looks cool it's a new
citizen news it's in news I said they're
coming someone who said said I wouldn't
wear one cuz I know if I got ahold of
someone's tacit joking to death with it
exactly yeah especially if it's like a
sticky tie and if it's the win if it's a
wins or not the best weather ties that
shit's preposterous what kind of time a
leather tie strap work yeah we really
have a strap murder wedding the murder
around your neck and but also
uncomfortable yeah it does look cool
something about it mysterious men get
pushed into all kinds of things in
commercialism but that's cool if you
been if you listen to someone who really
cherishes a good suit talk about it
mm-hmm then you kind of get it they're
in love yes yeah yeah yeah it's nice
yeah some things some people really in
his suits they look at reckon like an
art form well yeah I mean there's my
Richie he had a whole thing he was
telling me about it he came into the
with a beautiful suit on mm-hmm and I
was like look at that [ __ ] suit man I
told him about the tie thing and he just
like shook his head he's a black belt in
jujitsu too though okay he didn't he
also like makes no sense to do that he
said well it does make sense but you
know he's like you know grab my tie
right no I'm not gonna happen he's
actually a black belt from hens Oh
Gracie mmm that guy we're talking about
earlier yeah but dude Guy Ritchie loves
suits but the way he talks about it like
you love suits to York ah I get it like
the way someone talks about like a
really well-made handmade shoe that you
got from some Italian cobbler and you're
like oh I get it
right you're wearing like a piece of art
like this is someone's are
but yes it is a boot right right but it
is also when you see that thing it
reminds you of Italy it reminds you of a
guy who actually made us yeah like
there's something [ __ ] cool about
that that we're definitely getting away
from in this like like someone who can
make a watch like if someone makes a wat
like they're taking all these things and
putting wheels in there and or you could
just get like a [ __ ] g-shock I've had
this watch longer than my daughter's
been alive thirty years it's amazing and
I and I have I've tried other watches
but I just it's a piece of me now is it
a Rolex yeah it's beautiful
I bought it back in the old MTV music
business days if you're a douche bag
then you had a diamond bezel around it
and now this is actually very popular
amongst rich women go to a loss harder
my former New York banker friend to go
to his dinner party and is like mom and
it's like three women here wearing my
watch is like still looks great I love
it it's not a classic but it's the goal
just kind of melts into me now and it's
a part of me and it's a reminder of a
different time yeah when it when this
[ __ ] mattered now is I don't care but
it's beautiful I think it's a cool thing
that but it's got a lot of
sentimentality right yeah if you go back
to the origin of wristwatches it's
amazing how long they've been around
pocket watches but the [ __ ] figured
out how to do that [ __ ] hundreds of
years ago they figured out when did they
figure out a pocket watch like what was
the year because that was the first one
you get on a chain you pull it up I
guess you had a wind it mm-hmm but the
fact that it worked like they put a
bunch of [ __ ] gears together in this
thing that you carried around everywhere
and it kept time when both my
grandparents died they died very close
to each other 16th centuries holy [ __ ]
is that a Hamilton 1510 in Nuremberg
Germany um it's a Peter hell Peter
henlon Henlein Henlein h en le I N and
he created the first pocket watch in
1510 according to Wikipedia the Italian
Italians were producing clocks small
enough to be worn on the person by the
earliest 16th century I'd be weird
wearing like a necklace clock like play
the place yeah just like Flavor Flav
that guy is 60 years
old and he's still wearing the clock
around his neck once once you know what
time it is remember those guys back in
MTV and they be on there were nuts there
in the street jumping around Flavor Flav
just doing his thing with the clock like
wow man that's still your gig yeah you
were talking about Mark Wahlberg the
other day and you know I do stat or with
him
I had a syndicated radio show and the
stations would put it on if I came to
their summer jam origin b-59 yeah a
summer long MTV's Adam curry and then
they had Marky Mark and the Funky Bunch
sisters with voices it's sometimes ub40
I would be cool if they were there every
weekend I go off to some bad top 40
radio station around the country and
that was what Greg Lally put together my
buddy and in Austin he he and I did that
and he was promoting all the artists and
so Marky Mark and the Funky Bunch it was
yeah he was just like you said like a
Calvin Klein underwear model cool guy
you know nice he didn't seem to be calm
and didn't cause a ruckus on the road or
anything and we stated some pretty
shitty places and all of a sudden he's
like mr. Hollywood and doing well I did
I liked it and never stopped
no like you started doing well and like
when the eighties yeah it's like it's
like Will Smith I mean we use invented
himself too we did Sega Genesis in
launch parties together yeah and he was
doing parents just don't understand yeah
I know it was great yeah amazing that's
him
no I wasn't yeah 18 maybe wasn't 17 not
just anyway he's been around forever
yeah and still doing I mean the fact
that he was able to reinvent himself too
is a major movie star - yeah amazing
fantastic good stories yeah when you
remembered the birth of the internet
when you remember first getting on in it
and then seeing the expansion was there
ever a moment when was the moment I
should say well obviously now today we
all realize it's out of control and it's
just wild it's a very strange thing
that's taking over our lives and then
with I want to talk about neural link to
its I'm sure you know something about
that about Elon Musk's invention Doral
Inc I know a little bit about
but when you're when you saw it kind of
getting away like when was the moment or
where you were like this is a very
strange thing that's never happened to
people before well I had the online part
figured out because I ran a bulletin
board you might remember those you could
call in normally like five lines and you
go in and do your business and then get
out all yours that oh this has got to be
early eighties no maybe even late 70s so
there's time for innovation there right
there's big long stretches where things
don't get any better
well the speeds got marginally better
people got more phone lines that the
computers you know we're able to do more
then there also some other things
happening we had Windows Windows 95 came
into play so now people were you know
we're in a different world of computing
it used to be Doss and people have you
know WordPerfect and and then all of a
sudden you know we have an interface on
top of it yeah we didn't have that there
so that started to teach people how to
deal with the environment so that was
all there but the Internet itself would
be 1987 and I logged in to get on the
unit you had to log in to a dial-up
account launched a PPP session or slip
and then you had to launch the software
on your computer and then you could open
a terminal and you could type things
like telnet and then a domain name or in
even an IP address you could connect to
someone else's thing and kind of look
around it was just all text-based but
that for me was like holy [ __ ] you can
connect from one to the next
I understood the hyperlinking I
understood how powerful that would be
and if I just had a little computer
today on my desk I had a Mac plus with a
gigantic external 20 megabytes Guzzi
harddrive 20 megabytes that's a that's
an empty word doc yeah you know so that
big thing like that it just lit was like
oh my god this is this is this is going
to be it
so the second moment was the Andreessen
with his HTTP demos a Brower
browser the web
and then the third moment was Carl Jacob
he's a investor maybe even on the board
at Facebook but he worked at Sun
Microsystems at the time and he
contacted me so cami I see what you're
doing I wanna send you a computer you
sent me as a son Voyager which is like a
portable a luggable with a LCD color
screen and this is you know 80 88
something like that a UNIX which is even
crazier and so he started to show me
stuff and he actually streamed a song
from his workstation in San Francisco to
my computer in Montclair New Jersey and
it played I had him on the phone here I
heard him started and then it came
through and it played on my on my
computer that I'd never seen this before
or heard it I was like [ __ ] broadcast we
can use this to broadcast and since that
moment I think that's the mission I've
been on and look at my mama I have
arrived here we are that's an amazing
story man that's cool as [ __ ] I love
hearing it from someone who was there
from the very first steps and you're we
used to have the yellow pages the
internet yellow pages which was a book I
still have it
it was published it was published here
you can look up everything in the yellow
pages that that was a business business
what yellow pages got [ __ ] right of
course that [ __ ] fell apart
he's what happened with newspapers
here's where the newspapers [ __ ] up
with the news when the internet came
around and there were I saw it other
people saw it Craig Newmark saw it and
it's classified because they were all
hoity-toity about that advertising model
but people they were really making the
money off the classified ads everybody
knows it everybody knew it and that's
what Craigslist who who tried to sell it
to Tribune was a Tribune or Hearst maybe
it was Hearst for just a couple million
bucks and it's like now we're not
interested we don't need it not invented
he or whatever and so he ate up there
they're they're classified business
overnight and they were left holding the
bag saying well we have cool news to
advertise on well-known I'm
put some in there but now it was about
the class-wise that's where the money
came from Wow
Dvorak can tell the story of Alice Alice
makes a show you can tell the story
about Craig Newmark and how they passed
on it and he does that very well the
classified ads do they even have them no
newspapers are gone obits dead people is
that still the good business yeah of
course they have some but no not really
how often do you hold a physical
newspaper in your hand and read it
whenever right whenever I'm at the
airport I always buy the newspapers yeah
because I don't want to be on my phone
right just read the newspaper yeah yeah
do use Android no iPhone I have a strip
down
I called cloaked no sim card VPN piehole
there's a lot of different parts on it
that I do carry it's iPhone 7 if I need
to but there's no ignore other apps on
it no extra apps just just blanket yeah
so that's not that in case of emergency
yeah if I need to do something yeah like
I want to use the GPS and also has an
iCloud account that's not you know it's
not in my main iCloud accounts all right
that's I'm trying to make that Adam
curry and remove my other digital
footprint I did it move it over a little
bit so or something at least confuse it
a bit Wow whatever happened to wasn't
there a blockchain phone that was going
to be released there's a number of of
interesting projects that are Linux
based I'm trying to think of the one
that's on the a lot of its crowdfunded
this company actually they make laptops
that are completely they'd all all
open-source Hardware [ __ ] Jamie can you
find what was the name of that country
it's uh I feel stupid now it's the weed
it definitely they but they crowd fun
but they've had very successful
crowdfunding with Linux laptops with
open-source hardware because that's
that's really where you have to look for
the problems because you know
advertising it's an insatiable thing
that these companies are hooked on and
so they and the the data they have to
keep getting data from us that's the
system so you know when we start to cut
it down they move to the hardware they
move to different different types of
ways of getting data and you know right
now I mean you still can't hide from
cell phone triangulation there's all
kinds of ways people can find you that's
really the biggest problem if you can
track someone's location you can build
their life add a credit card to that
meanie john c Dvorak's wife she does the
company's taxes a very family business
and she kind of I think she used to do
some kind of auditing in the past and
she'll call up and say oh here's what I
always see you do and she'll tell me
exactly what I do where I go when I like
to eat out she has all these patterns
and she just does it for fun
do you have GPS in your car yeah you
can't get rid of it I mean there's no
they no manufacturer after probably 2015
allows you to completely turn off
tracking well you got an iPhone 7 once
killer just 69 Corvette but that's the
point
everything everything is built in and
yeah I mean I think that didn't really
start until like mm well they sold it to
us in a great way with on call you know
like boom I'm upside down on call help
is on the way
what is this Jamie I typed in a Libra
there you go Libra thank you what did
what did you type in crowdfunded Linux
fantastic yeah Brett here ISM pure isn't
a they make a bunch of product yeah do
you mean laptop or phone they make both
so they make the laptops the phone
they're coming but there's other
projects as well it looks like a real
phone but he isn't here's my problem
he's my problem what it's still gonna
bleep in blue right I don't want it
right it's gonna be on you I'll buy it
of course I want to have it because I
have control over keeping it off and not
using it when I'm on the road but as a
basic thing if I'm at home and I just
want to surf I'm sitting down yeah I'd
rather use that
saluté Apple I kind of trust Apple to a
degree you know they're pretty good
about not selling stuff they know so
their Maps is would would be what I use
I trust that yeah but only as far as I
can throw them you know I mean I'm sure
there's a million guys going curry you
have no idea how they try I do so but I
just try to make less data what do you
think happen with Google that were they
removed don't be evil I think it was do
no evil do no evil that's right people
get that wrong
like which is which is which is Eve no I
mean it's one of those things that it's
like a Mandela effect okay right like
the bernstein bear yeah like Mandela but
for whatever reason well that's a they
okay so these guys who grew up you know
under you don't be evil mmm I thought it
was don't do evil but that was in it was
in the s1 document and I remember
reading it and I thought okay I could be
so it is either way it doesn't maybe
they maybe they change that half way and
we're from don't be evil to don't don't
do you leo you don't either they
adjusted from do the right thing no it
was let's it says now I guess nicer Oh
either way anyway whatever the word so
these guys didn't grow up by accident
this is gonna be my big Google
conspiracy theory just I'll give it to
you it's one way of explaining it maybe
I'm foolish okay they had a lot of help
from conspirators their main their main
boost was the acquisition of keyhole and
this was a you have to know that the
company Inc you tell which is a venture
capital company which is the CIA's it's
not a secret the CIA's they would say
our CIA venture capital company and they
invest in stuff and they help the
keyhole acquisition and keyhole is the
mapping that's really what Google Maps
was the most important thing you can
have as a person's identity is where
they are these guys kind of grew up
young under oppression of Russia
so they both come from and they kind of
came into the system if you look at the
universities and the people involved on
how they were almost given some kind of
prizes for things they did I mean
there's an alternative story to the Gen
narrative of how Google came to be so I
think there was a lot of intelligence
people involved in this involvement
setting it up and the psychology of
Larry and Sergey some psychologists have
analyzed and I've listened to a lot of
different people is that they kind of
become what their oppressor was to them
and it's not really I don't think
they're bad guys but this is psych
psychosis that happens if you grow up in
some kind of stressed-out situation you
know people who have been have you
abused often abuse others right and so I
think that's what's going on the problem
is I love all the technology I love what
all these companies and everybody's
doing the business model is just [ __ ]
humanity it is it's [ __ ] us by giving
away data yeah influencing people not
letting us is that data not letting us
share in in the revenue of the data
right or having some control over it
there should be some sort of legislation
that recognizes what data is and that
they look at it in terms of like like
its commodity and saying like selling
and buying and selling well I think
there is there is some of that is there
some that really evenly balances it or
or looks at it for what it really is
like well what is data I mean what is my
money is data money and money is not
providing a service all data it's all
data yeah it is all day you have to have
it has to be a trust relationship and
it's if their business model is what at
it as it is now if they don't change it
no legislation will stop them from
getting around the problem or now it's
you get free [ __ ] and we get your data
you get a free browse here's the
interest of your day here's the
interesting thing the Internet is
although no longer quite the same way
with up upstream and downstream being
equal due to you know the cable
companies and how they've implemented
your personal connection we can still do
our own servers you know it doesn't all
have to be on YouTube on Facebook on
Twitter there's an entire was talking
about mastodons No Agenda social calm is
our own social network it's with
open-source software without algorithm
and you'll be federated all these other
servers much the way the World Wide Web
grew up and and there's this mechanism
for communicating with each other and so
it's kind of Twitter meets email only
it's just it looks like Twitter just but
you control a lot more of how it works
and your community can be a small little
community and you have no one come in
you can block people or just say I only
want these cool people to also connect
or that server to connect it's all good
so you have all these kind of almost
like an ancestry.com tree that branches
to all these different places called the
Federation if we build upon those kinds
of things and don't let other companies
or companies at all there's no reason
for them to get involved it's very cheap
with a believe it or not a Linux laptop
you can get started any kid can learn
how to do it they should be teaching it
at school how to set up a server how to
get around some of the hurdles
understand how an email server works and
we will not need these companies we can
have all the joy and a lot of the
downside but there won't be a Twitter
police there'll be only your own little
community say hey we don't like this guy
we're just gonna block you or your whole
community or we would love to have you
guys with us and we can happen to us
similarly and that's how you build these
networks and eventually you connect to
each other on the back end somehow
anyway how often do you think I mean how
long do you think it's going to be
before we're implementing augmented
reality into our life in that way in
like a social media context because you
kind of got augmented reality already
through your ears yeah so would be
unfair of me to say that it it's mm-hmm
it's augmented in that it's enhancing
but it's not I have enhanced it in ways
that are particular to me but it's not
some algorithm really determining things
that I should hear and I'm in total
control of how that works and how it
sounds I don't see the the case for
augmented reality I just don't see it I
mean when you think about with the
apples trying to do with their glasses
well I think it's trying to get people
from doing this to doing this yes
probably
that is probably that's all that it is
that's a whole that it is but it's also
probably adding to the experience right
if you can have like
little animated fairies everywhere you
go that you see through your Apple
glasses everything else looks the same
if you ever go to the Haunted Mansion
ride at Disneyland
yes look you know as a ghost sit right
next to you if I see you as one of those
glasses on learn some that [ __ ] movie
I'm gonna keep you on your [ __ ] head
boom like dhalsim what if it makes life
so much crisper and brighter you put
these babies on it syncs up to the
little chip that you have in the middle
of your brain it gives you this pleasure
feeling and you all sudden different
words flowers man I'm always looking for
the conditioning you know this getting
us ready for these moments and so I
think a beautiful moment is this
coronavirus where the testing is someone
holding a gun like sensor to your head I
mean that's preparing people for the for
the barcode or the chip you know it's
like oh yeah click let me do like a pet
like hey they testing just to go to a
hospital yeah the test and takes a
couple of days that I think they have a
test they'll go down a couple hours but
they swab deep in your throat or deep in
your nose like so it sounds kind of
annoying this whole thing is very very
spooky well it seems they're conditioned
100 years look Joe we're conditioned
we're conditioned through horror movies
for this I mean my favorite part of this
script as it unravels was the Pope
sneezing at coughing oh my god the Pope
he's in Italy he has coronavirus World
War II like if the Pope dies this will
freak out the world and some we talked
about on the show we're waiting like oh
my god and today they announced the Pope
is fine he does he's been tested he does
not have corona virus so thank God I
think this is sadly we're reacting in
all the wrong ways this is completely
theological what's going on it's very
logical and this is there's it's the
death rate and the amount of people who
are infected that is misunderstood and
so people just throw numbers everywhere
and and meanwhile I mean even the New
England Journal of Medicine which
includes dr. Fauci who's on the on the
on the team and who's been around in
this business for a long time through
the Obama administration Bush
administration yeah he's been around
said look this is probably going to be
no worse than a severe seasonal flu
now we know that seasonal flu is can
kill quite a lot of people you know
could be twenty thirty thousand so in
those aspects it's kind of the same but
it's being presented in in a
sensationalistic way that were
completely programmed to respond to
remember we already have enlarged
amygdalas because of all the triggering
and woke neskowin on so give us a little
it's true Joe give us a little bit of
fear with this thing that were
conditioned through all kinds of horror
movies and Netflix just had the pandemic
movie on just a couple months ago so
we're primed we're primed to be suckered
into something and part of it may be the
Patriot Act which never what ever is
going with the pandemic there's always
something going on the background do you
think whenever there's something going
on with the pandemic then they use it as
an opportunity to sneak stuff in yes I'm
looking for the pandemic appropriate the
spending bill someone was trying to talk
to me about that with natural disasters
or any college it always happened
mmm-hmm that there's automatically an
understanding that people are willing to
do things they wouldn't normally be
willing to do so this is when you move
in with new registration it's the
amendments so you have a bill and the
bill will be financing for coronavirus
whatever that means the president wanted
two and a half million two million I
think like a million half was already
kind of there and you stuff a bunch of
[ __ ] in that bill well exactly and it's
like a piece of the patriarchy may
actually get passed in that because it's
kind of like you cannot vote against
this [ __ ] cuz how can you vote against
pandemic saver how can you vote against
patriot truck the patriot well this is
what a lot there are a lot of people in
congress right now trying to break the
patriot act apart because yeah this is
the spying though or the government can
just spy on you and we've been talking
about some of that it's not cool yeah
this all really was implemented right
after the September 11th it was already
really yeah it was gonna say Oh Benny
from the CIA guy said look they were
ready to spy on people long before then
totally bring it up mm-hmm
they crazy they Adam I hate to end this
but it's 3:10 oh [ __ ] we've literally
done this for three hours that feels so
good it was awesome and
it was better than I expected I expected
it to be awesome and it was even more
awesome I really enjoyed it we got to do
it more often I'd love to and thank you
so much my pleasure having me on thanks
for looking creating this thing man you
know you're a big part of it you know
your your ideas of broadcasting for sure
part of the seeds that led to the you
know to meet me doing this so thank you
thank you very much you're more than
welcome but thank you and thank you know
everyone who really is around your show
and all the comedian's it's a I can die
a happy man pretty much not planning yet
stay alive I love you all right thanks
bye everybody
[Music]
Wow that was a long chat
[Music]